THAT THERE IS A TOTAL OF FIFTEEN
BILLS -- ON TODAY'S AGENDA WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM AS OF YET BUT
TO FOR EFFICIENCY WE'RE GONNA
START.
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE -- WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS ON CAN SET THESE BILLS
BILLS INCLUDE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB --
TWO EIGHTY SIX IT ALSO ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN SB SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT TO ENSURE THAT WE COMPLETE
OUR WORK TODAY.
I REALLY ACID -- OF THE AUTHORS
AND WITNESSES -- TO KEEP THE
PRESENTATIONS BRIEF CONCISE AND
BRIEF -- AND SAME WITH -- ARE --
WITNESSES AS WELL SO WITH THAT
SENATOR PAN I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
READY TO GO.
GOOD MORNING.
TO YOU GOT TO BILLS TWENTY ONE I
DO THEM IN.
WHICH WERE ALL WHAT YOU
DETERMINE WHICH BILL YOU'D LIKE
TO GO FIRST WOULD -- WILL GO
AHEAD AND START WITH THIS BEFORE
TWENTY ONE ALL RIGHT ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR THAT'S A FILE ORDERS BUT
ALL RIGHT THAT'S CORRECT YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS --
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER NINE
MILLION CHILDREN.
WHAT CHILD WELFARE IS ALWAYS
BEEN A PRIORITY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE STILL HAVE AMONG?
THE WORST OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN
HEALTH EDUCATION JUVENILE
JUSTICE FOR EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA
RANKS FORTY FIRST AND FOR PER
PUPIL SPENDING CALIFORNIA RANKS
FORTY THIRD FOR THE RATE OF
YOUNG CHILDREN RECEIVING
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS.
AND HALF OF ALL CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE RENDERED
FOUR OR MORE ADVERSE TODD HAD
EXPERIENCES WHICH ARE MORE
LIKELY LEAD TO CHRONIC DISEASES
ADULTHOOD.
WE DO HAVE MULTIPLE STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
PROVIDING DIRECT SERVICES THAT
AIM ALLEVIATING THESE CHALLENGES
AND YET WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE
NEED TO MOVE ON SOME OF THESE
MEASURES.
OF CHILD WELL BEING.
A CHILDREN'S CABINET MADE UP OF
KEY AGENCY LEADERS CAN HELP
MOBILIZE EFFORTS AND RESOURCES
ROUTE STATE PRIORITIES FOR
CHILDREN IMPROVE EFFICIENCY AND
SERVICE DELIVERY CROSS STATE
LOCAL DEPARTMENTS.
AS BEFORE TWENTY ONE WOULD
ESTABLISH THE CHILDREN'S CABINET
DEVELOP A SHARED VISION AMONG
THE BRANCH OF THE GOVERNMENT NOR
TO PRODUCE.
A CHILD A FAMILY OUTCOMES THIS
CABINET I WOULD BE QUARTERLY
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT A
REPORT EVERY TWO YEARS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE
COORDINATION OF SERVICES. TO
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES I
WANT THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE IN A CRAFTING.
THESE -- SPECIFICS.
THE NATIONAL GOVERNORS
ASSOCIATION CONSIDERS CHILDREN'S
CABINETS A BEST PRACTICE AND
EARLY SIXTEEN OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE A CHILDREN'S CABINET.
THE NATIONAL GOVERNORS
ASSOCIATION HAS ALSO SET FORTH
GUIDING PRINCIPLES FOR
ESTABLISHING A CHILDREN'S
CABINET AND A LOOK FORWARD TO
UTILIZING THESE PRINCIPLES A
WORKING WITH STAPLES REFINED
CABINETS SPECIFIC GOALS ENSURE
SUCCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION -- SO
WITH THAT -- OBVIOUSLY WERE
SUBCOMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK IN THIS AREA I
THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
WORK AND I WILL BE --
RECOMMENDING AND I BUILT ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB.
FIVE TWELVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR THE OUT THE PRESENT
SB FIVE TWELVE I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH -- MY OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS
WHICH WILL ACCEPT TO ADD A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET TO THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
SB FIVE TWELVE TAKES THE FIRST
CRITICAL STEP TWO IS CREATING A
NEW LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS OUR L. TSS BENEFIT FOR
CALIFORNIA.
THE NEED FOR THIS LEGISLATION
THIS NEW BENEFIT IS URGENT
ALMOST EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE
EITHER OLDER ADULTS ARE
INDIVIDUALS WITH PHYSICAL MENTAL
DISABILITIES CURRENTLY LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS POPULATION WILL GROW
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE NEXT
DECADE.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY CALIFORNIANS
LACK ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE L. TSS
SERVICES.
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
ARE NOT ADEQUATELY COVERED BY
MEDICARE AND MOST CALIFORNIANS
CANNOT AFFORD TO PURCHASE
PRIVATE LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE.
PAYING OUT OF POCKET FOR LTE
ASSESSES THE HIGHLY EXPENSIVE
AND CREATES A SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL SOCIAL BURDEN FOR
FAMILIES.
ALTERNATIVE LEE CALIFORNIANS
MUST SPEND DOWN THROUGH THEIR
LIFE SAVINGS TO BECOME ELIGIBLE
FOR MEDICARE NOW. TOO OFTEN THIS
IS THE PRIMARY MEANS BY WHICH
OLDER ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES CURRENTLY
RECEIVE ACCESS TO PAID LONG TERM
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES.
MEDI CAL IS A CRITICAL SAFETY
NET BUT THIS SYSTEM IS BEING
OVER BURDEN AND CERTAINLY -- AT
HAVING TO BE SUPPORTED BY
TAXPAYERS.
INDIVIDUALS SHOULD HAVE TO
IMPOVERISH THEMSELVES SPEND
THROUGH THEIR LIFE SAVINGS AND
OUR CHILDREN'S INHERITANCE OR TO
FOREGO WORKING IN A GENERATING
EARNED INCOME IN ORDER TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SERVICES THEY NEED
TO LIVE.
INDEPENDENT HIGH QUALITY LIVES.
THIS LEGISLATION IS CREATING A
FRAMEWORK FOR THE MANAGEMENT OF
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
BLOTTER SUBJECT SERVICES
SUPPORTS BENEFIT TO BE AVAILABLE
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS SPECIFICALLY
SB FIVE TWELVE CREATES THE
INFRASTRUCTURE MODELED AFTER THE
CALCIUM OR SECURE CHOICE PROGRAM
FOR WITH.
NGUYEN CALIFORNIA'S RATE TO THE
SIGN IN FINANCE AND YOUBENEFIT
INDEED THIS LEGISLATION
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
AGING AND DISABILITY ALLIANCE
WHICH REPRESENTS TWENTY
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM OF L. T..
STAKEHOLDERS WE NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD NOW TO PUT THESE
CRITICAL PIECES IN PLACE SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD
WITH BENEFIT AND FINANCING
DESIGN.
WE WILL -- I PLEASED TO HAVE IN
SUPPORT TESTIMONY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS AND
A. R. P. EXPECT THE ASPIRIN I
THOUGHT THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
CRISTINA MILLS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS A
VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE.
FOR AT PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AN AGING COMMUNITY AND
INTRODUCING OUR WONDERFUL
SPEAKER TODAY FROM SACRAMENTO
CAME LATE TRIP TO TALK ABOUT HOW
THE BILL WOULD.
HELP HER IF IT WERE PASSED WE
ARE IN SUPPORT.
SPORTING GOOD MORNING -- AS
MENTIONED MY NAME'S CAM LATER
OUT I AM THIRTY THREE YEARS OLD
AND I LIVE WITH A DISABILITY.
I WAS BORN WITHOUT ARMS OR LEGS.
ALSO AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED I
WAS BORN AND RAISED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I AM A REGISTERED
VOTER -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND I MEAN HERE IN SUPPORT
FOR IT SB. FIVE TWELVE FOR AS
FAR BACK AS I CAN REMEMBER.
I WAS ALWAYS TOLD THAT WORKING
FULL TIME AND KEEPING MY LONG
TERM SUPPORTS AND SERVICES WOULD
JUST NOT BE POSSIBLE.
INSTEAD OF JUST ACCEPTING THAT
IS FACT I DECIDED TO CHALLENGE
IT.
I WANTED TO COME HOME AT NIGHT
KNOWING THAT I SPENT MY DAY NOT
ONLY DOING MY PART IN
CONTRIBUTING AND GIVING BACK TO
MY COMMUNITIES.
BUT I DID MY PART AS AN AMERICAN
TAXPAYER WHO COULD CONTRIBUTE TO
MY COUNTRY.
A FEW YEARS BACK WHAT I HAD
ALWAYS DREAMED BECAME A REALITY
WHEN I WAS OFFERED MY VERY FIRST
INTERNSHIP.
THAT INTERNSHIP TURNED INTO A
PART TIME JOB.
AND EVENTUALLY AFTER HARD WORK.
MY FULL TIME MY PART TIME JOB
TURNED INTO A FULL TIME -- JOB.
THAT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT
DECISION TO MAKE TO ACCEPT THAT
JOB.
BECAUSE I KNEW THERE WAS AN
INCOME THRESHOLD. TO WHAT I
COULD EARN IN ORDER TO KEEP MY
LONG TERM SUPPORTS AND SERVICES.
NONE THE LESS I DECIDED TO
PERSEVERE AND MOVE FORWARD.
ALWAYS MAKING SURE THAT I NEVER
HAD THAT INCOME LIMIT AS TO PUT
MY LONG TERM SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES AT RISK.
BUT BUT IN DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN MY FATHER
PASSED AWAY.
AND I BEGAN TO RECEIVE SOME OF
HIS BENEFITS.
THIS MEANT THAT I COULD NO
LONGER KEEP MY EARNED INCOME.
AND MY LONG TERM SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES.
SO I WAS FACED WITH THE CHOICE.
TO EITHER KEEP MY HEALTH CARE
AND MY PERSONAL CARE ATTENDANTS
THAT ENABLES ME TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY.
OR TO QUIT MY JOB.
A JOB THAT I HAD WORKED SO HARD.
FOR A JOB WHERE I WAS GROWING MY
SKILLS IN.
AND HAD THE WHERE I HAD BUILT MY
COMMUNITY AND MY NETWORK THROUGH.
I THOUGHT ROB THAT I WAS FORCED
TO BE DUG GIVE UP EVERYTHING AND
I ALSO FELT DISAPPOINTED THAT I
WAS GOING TO REMAIN ON THE
SYSTEM.
BUT SINCE THERE'S NO WAY I CAN
AFFORD OUT OF POCKET COSTS FOR
MY LONG TERM SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES ON MY EARNED INCOME
ALONE.
I DID QUIT MY JOB.
SO THAT I CAN MAINTAIN LIVING AT
HOME AND LIVING INDEPENDENTLY.
I AM NOT ALONE.
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR FACED
WITH THESE KINDS OF DECISIONS.
WHETHER WE CHOOSE TO PURSUE JOBS
CAREERS AND EARN AN INCOME OR TO
KEEP THE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THAT WE NEED TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY.
THIS DECISION IS NOT FAIR AND IT
IS ALWAYS PLACED ON PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE TWELVE THERE WILL BE MORE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF SO THAT WE ARE NOT
FACED WITH THESE UNFAIR
SITUATIONS.
THERE WILL BE MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR US TO BE GIVEN THE CHANCE TO
PURSUE A CAREER.
WITHOUT RISKING OUR SERVICES.
THE SERVICES THAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO LIVE THE LIFE WE
DESERVE. TO LIVE SAFELY AND
INDEPENDENTLY IN OUR OWN HOMES
AND WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
I STRONGLY LOOK FORWARD TO GOING
BACK TO WORK AND HAVING THE
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TWELVE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK SPEAKER AND THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING I NEED A WHILE HER WELL
WITH A OR P. AND I'M HERE TO
INTRODUCE COLORADO CAMERINO HE'S
AN A. R. P. VOLUNTEER.
WHO WORKS IN THE CAPITAL INCOMES
US ALL THE WAY FROM FAIRFIELD --
I DO WANT TO STRESS BEFORE CON
RADO BEGINS THAT THIS BILL IS A
NATIONAL AND STATE PRIORITY FOR
A OR P..
AND OF COURSE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY AND AS YOU
SAID I'M FROM FAIRFIELD.
I WORK FOR YOU.
YEAH SO -- I'M ALSO AN AIR FORCE
VETERAN OF TWO AND A ONE YEAR
SERVICE.
AND I HAVE BEEN A CARE GIVER FOR
MULTIPLE FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND TO SUPPORT WHAT THE CENTER
OF DOCTOR PAN JUST SO SAD I WANT
TO TELL YOU MY STORY ABOUT --
TAKING CARE OF MY FAMILIES HAD
GOTTEN ME TO TO GET INVOLVED
ABOUT THESE AND A. R. P. S.
MENTION.
IS SAID DEDICATED TO EMPOWERING
AMERICANS FIFTY AND OLDER.
BECAUSE THE THE COST OF EL TSS
IS MORE THAN WHAT THEY COULD OF
PUT OFF.
FOR THE A FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
HOUSE OLD -- MEDIAN INCOME IS
ONLY HALF.
OF THE NURSING HOME CARE -- BUT
IT'S A HUNDRED FIFTEEN HUNDRED
SIXTEEN THOUSAND FOR A PRIVATE
ROOM AND NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
FOR A SHARED ROOM.
AND HIRING A HOME CAN HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER IS ALSO EXPENSIVE --
JUST THE THIRTY HOURS A WEEK
COST THIRTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND THESE NUMBERS OF COURSE THE
NOT LINE UP.
AND NOT ONLY MY WIFE AND MY
SIBLINGS AND MY IN LAWS -- SPENT
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OUT
OF POCKET TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
FAMILY.
I LOVED ONES.
SO -- ABOUT A YEAR AGO I LOST
BOTH MY FATHER AND MY MOTHER IN
LAW IN FACT YESTERDAY WAS MY DAD
SO ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY.
FOREST FUNERAL.
AND MY WIFE AND HER SIX SIBLINGS
TOOK CARE OF MY MOTHER IN LAW
WHILE SHE WAS DYING OF
PANCREATIC CANCER. ONE SISTER IN
LAW FLIES FROM BLUE FROM -- WEST
VIRGINIA STATE WEEKS AT A TIME.
TAKE HER TURN ANOTHER SISTER IN
LAW FROM NORTH CAROLINA THAT
SAME THING.
AND THE OTHER SIBLINGS TOOK
TURNS MY WIFE AND I DROVE IS
SOMETIMES WE FLEW FROM FAIRFIELD.
THE TORRANCE CALIFORNIA. TO TAKE
OUR TURN.
IN NINE AND MY DAD -- WAS NINETY
ONE YEARS OLD WHEN HE PASSED
AWAY -- LAST YEAR LIKE I SAID
YESTERDAY WAS THE FUNERAL STYLE
ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY.
AND AT THE TIME THAT WE WERE HE
WAS.
THE LAST FEW YEARS OF HIS LIFE
THE IT WAS REALLY HARD FOR US
THE SIBLINGS WITH TOOK TURNS
ALSO.
I THANK GOD FOR BIG FILIPINO
FAMILIES.
HERE NOW WE TAKE CARE OF I LOVE
ONCE BUT THEN AGAIN IT'S ALL
ONLY BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
CHOICE.
YEAH SO -- YEAH HE HE REQUIRED --
DIALYSIS THREE TIMES A WEEK.
AND THAT HE HAD THE A LOT OF
APPOINTMENTS WEEKLY.
AND FOR ME. TO TAKE HIM TO HIS
APPOINTMENT WAS A ONE HOLDING A
FAIR BECAUSE I DRIVE FROM
FAIRFIELD.
PICKED THEM UP IN A WORD TOOK
INTO HIS DOCTORS AND SAN LEANDRO
OR FREMONT [inaudible]
SO -- IT'S KIND OF POWERS THE
SAY BUT IT'S ALSO A RELIEF WHEN
THEY PASSED AWAY.
YOU KNOW SO -- AND THAT'S MY
STORY AND THAT IS WHY -- I AM A
AND BIG SUPPORT AND PASSIONATELY
IN SUPPORT OF NOT ONLY A HAPPY
BUT WHAT THEY SUPPORT THE SB.
FIVE ONE TWO I ITS PERSONAL -- I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK OUT ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS.
AND THAT MIGHT HAVE HELPED MY
FAMILY AND MILLIONS OF OTHER
CALIFORNIANS TO THE HIGH COST OF
A L. T. S. S..
AND I HOPE AND I IMAGINE A TIME
WHEN FAMILIES LIKE MINE WILL
HAVE BETTER OPTIONS WHEN THEY
WANTED THIS MAN SPENT ASKED
MONTHS OUT OF POCKET.
AND ONE HAD TO TRY TO TAKE TIME
OFF FROM WORK THAT'S ANOTHER
THING WE WE TOOK TIME OFF FROM
WORK TAKE CARE OF OUR TOOK CARE
OF OUR FAMILIES.
AND ALSO.
HELLO DEALING WITH LOST WAGES
AND FUTURES ALSO SEE HERE IN
INCOME.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR
STORE BEFORE I GO TO OTHER
WITNESSES IN KIM I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU.
FOR SO ARTICULATELY -- YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT -- YOUR ISSUES AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL --
TO YOU AND YOU KNOW SO MANY
OTHERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WITNESSES AND SUPPORTS PLEASE --
STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU
REPRESENT AND IN SUPPORT.
FOR I'M THE THE BRUNO FIRM.
AIR POLLUTED TO MONNING.
I AM SO THE BEEN THERE FOR ME
THEN.
GO.
AND THERE WITH WE DID THE MOVIE
DID THEM.
WHEN THE OWNER OF?
THE IN THE NEW WORLD.
I'M SUCH A BETTER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND OTHER SPEECH
DISABILITY AS A RESULT OF
SEVERAL POLICY GAME [inaudible]
KNOWING. NINE NINE WHERE THEY
WILL BE AND DO A ROUTINE BUT
WHEN THEY SIDE HER BROTHER WILL
BE INTERPRETING FOR HER TODAY
AND THE YEAH I MEAN YOU THE
PHONE -- LIVE THREE FOUR FOUR IN
JUNE.
AND THEN WHEN THE BIG LOAN.
THEN THEN BAND WITH.
GOOD THEN THEM BLOOM I'M HERE
JUST FOR SB FIVE ONE TWO IS A
MEMBER OF HAND IN HAND TO
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS NETWORK
NETWORK OF EMPLOYEES OF NANNIES
HOUSE CLEANERS AND HOME CARE
ATTENDANTS.
WORKING FOR DIGNIFIED AND
RESPECTFUL WORKING CONDITIONS
THAT BENEFIT BOTH IMPORT WORKERS
AND ENQUIRING IN WOOING WITH THE
NEW YEAR AND THEN MOVED TO MOVE
WHERE.
WE WERE AND DID.
ON THE AIR AND YOU.
WON'T ME.
WITH THE WITH THE KEURIG.
DO YOU LIVE DAILY LIVING.
EMPLOY PERSONAL CARE ATTENDANTS
THROUGH PUBLICLY FUNDED HOME
CARE WHO SUPPORT ME WITH
CRITICAL ACTIVITIES OF DAILY
LIVING AND WITH THEM AND THEN
NÁN WITH THEM.
NUMBER NAY WILL DO IT THEN YOU'D
BE GREEN.
NEW FOOD VERY FEW FOODS THE
FIFTEEN GOING THROUGH ON THE
VIOLIN WITH THE PROVEN DO YOU.
IN THE BOOK PHONE.
NINE THE DAILY K<c.cyan>. TO THE</c>
TERM FOR THE MARINE.
MEANING GO RIPPLING LIVES.
DO MOVE TO CLOSE -- FOR FOR BOTH
ME THREE FERNANDO DO.
WELL MAKE TO THEIR GROUP TO
BRING FOOD ON THEIR OWN.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY CALIFORNIANS
MAKE TOO MUCH QUALIFY FOR
PUBLICLY FUNDED HOME CARE TO
MAKE TOO LITTLE TO PAY FOR IT
ALL ON THEIR OWN.
AND THE MOVE THE BRUNO AND ON
THE WINDOW.
FOR ROOM TO ROOM.
WELL THE MEANING FERNANDO
WINNING.
INSTEAD THEY MUST DEPEND ON
UNDERPAID AND OVERWORKED FAMILY
CARE GIVERS OR MAY EVEN END UP
AN INSTITUTION WIND WONDER WOULD
GRIEVE.
I HAVE BRING [inaudible]
MOVE FORWARD.
GOING TO MEAN.
THERE WOULD BE COOL.
THEN THOUGH SO BOOTH.
DO YOU.
AND THE NEW THROUGH A FOOD OF
YOUR OWN.
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING LISA COLEMAN WITH
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PROUD MEMBERS OF THE KATE
ORGANIZATION AND JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT TO THE MEMBERS.
THAT LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS IT'S NOT NECESSARILY A
FUNCTION OF AGE IS A FUNCTION OF
HEALTH.
AND THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT AND
THE FAMILY IMPACT AS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM TESTIMONY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING OF COLD ALL THE
WITH THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
WE ARE ALSO MEMBERS OF KATE AT
AND STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
SHOULD HAMPTON WITH LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OR SIX
HUNDRED NOT FOR PROFIT PROVIDERS
OF SENIOR AFFORDABLE CARE
HOUSING AND SERVICES FOR OLDER
ADULTS IN THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES.
ALSO A MEMBER OF KATE AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK.
MORNING MR CHAIRING COMMITTEE
CRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON
REPRESENTING YOU W. WE REPRESENT
A HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND I JUST US
WORKERS.
STRONG SUPPORT AND WANT TO SAY
THAT WE HAVE WITH OUR COALITION
VISION TO CREATE SOMETHING.
TRULY ONCE IN A GENERATION THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FROM OWN COST
OF LONG CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
RETIRED AMERICANS WE REPRESENT
OVER ONE MILLION SENIORS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS IS A TOP
PRIORITY BILL THIS YEAR.
GOOD MORNING MR JR MEMBERS
TIFFANY WHITE WITH AS A YOU
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND LONG TERM CARE MEMBERS
AND SUPPORT AND ALSO A MEMBER OF
CAGE.
THANK YOU.
MORNING MR TERM MEMBERS TREAT
ANDERSON WITH THE ARK IN UNITED
CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION ALSO MEMBERS
CICADA IN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IT MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE HI ANGELI LIEBERMAN IT
WITH ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATORS OFFICE.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
RESPECTIVELY RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU -- AKILI NAZARIAN EVER
SINCE SAID I'M WITH THE FILIPINO
WORKER CENTER OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
MYSTIC WORKER COALITION WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TWELVE THIS
IS IMPORTANT FOR PROVIDING
DIGNITY NOT ONLY TO THOSE WHO --
ARE RECEIVING CARE AND AND
DESERVE QUALITY CARE LIKE.
OF HOME CARE WORKERS WHEN THEY
GET OLDER ALSO OR WHEN THE WHEN
THEY NEED CARE THEMSELVES -- BUT
ALSO YES SO NOT ONLY THOSE WHO
NEED CARE BUT ALSO FOR THE CARE
GIVERS THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HI GOOD MORNING I'M
TERRY VILLASENOR FONG WORKER
LEADER.
FROM PUTTING A WORKERS CENTURY I
AM ALSO HERE -- REPRESENTING
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOMESTIC
WORKERS SO LIKE -- ACCU SAID.
WE ALL NEED TO HOW LONG TERM
CHARACTERS WE ARE.
TAKING CARE OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THE CONSUMER IS AND
YOU KNOW.
BUT WHEN WE GET TO THAT AGE WE
ALSO NEED LONG TERM CARE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD MORNING THIS IS A
AMERICA FROM THE FILIPINO WORKER
CENTER AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT.
FIVE ONE TO ORDER GUARD
RESERVISTS THAT THOSE WE NEED
THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S DANIELLE I'M HERE WITH
THE PROMOTE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
CENTER IN THE CALIFORNIA
DOMESTIC WORKERS COALITION AND
WE ARE HERE TO SUPPORT SB FIVE
TWELVE AS WELL [inaudible]
THANKS.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
TORY I NOW WITH FILIPINO WORKER
CENTER AND CWC AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
SB FIVE TWELVE TO SUPPORT IT
FROM THE ABLE TO FOLKS AND LOW
INCOME AND OLDER FOLKS THANK YOU.
YOU.
GOOD MORNING ROXANNE GOAL
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS WHICH IS
AN ASSOCIATION OF SMALL SIX BEDS
ARE FEWER RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY AND
DEVELOP THEM THE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED.
INSTRUCTS APART [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING GERRY PASS FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS.
A TURN MEMBERS WE ARE
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORTERS OF UP
SOONER PANS BILL WHERE MEMBERS
OF CAT AND WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WHERE A MEMBER
OF THE ALLIANCE IN IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR TESTIMONY --
I I DON'T IMAGINE THERE I DON'T
WANT TO BEAR CITY BUDDY NOW BUT
EIGHTY OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL I
WOULDN'T THINK SO -- SO TURN OF
THE MEMBERS.
ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS [inaudible]
SENATE.
YES SIR YES -- DOCTOR PAYMENT
I'D JUST LIKE TO CONGRATULATE
YOU FOR COMING FORWARD.
OBVIOUSLY WITH THE POPULATION
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM -- END OF
COURSE YOU KNOW I REPRESENT
VETERANS IN NAY TO OUR COMEY
SENIORS THE BOOMERS THOSE WHO
SERVED IN KOREA AND VIETNAM AND
SO ON BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
MEN AND WOMEN THAT WE SEE OUT
HERE WITH DISABILITIES BECAUSE
THIS NOT ONLY.
PROTECTS AND SERVES -- THE THE
AGE THOSE ARE GETTING OLDER BUT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
THAT -- CANNOT AS WE'VE HEARD
HANDLE A FINANCIAL BURDEN SO I
THINK THIS IS A MILESTONE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT WILL
CERTAINLY OPEN DOORS TO SHOW OUR
APPRECIATION. FOR THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO GIVEN SO MUCH OUR
GREAT COUNTRY NIGHT CONGRATULATE%
YOU AND AND THANK EVERYONE WHO
APPEARED BEFORE US TODAY -- THE
BELIEVE SO MUCH IN IN OUR
SENIORS AND AND THOSE WHO
CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH TO OUR STATE
AND TO OUR COUNTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MALES.
THE CENTER PAN I JUST THINK -- I
I'M I'M I'M AMAZED AT THE RULES
ARE THE WAY THEY ARE I'M JUST
GLAD THAT YOU CAME FORWARD --
WIH THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
BUT EXPECT THIS -- BILL WILL GET
OUT AS SOON AS WE DO ABOUT IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHICH I
CAN'T SAY ANYTHING AND SO I
THINK THAT COALITION AND THAT'S
IN SUPPORT AND WHAT THANK -- AND
EXPECT THE ACTUALLY I BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU FOR
MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU TO ALL
THE WITNESSES PROCEED YOUR TIME.
OKAY SIR BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE
A A STEP UP TO THE PLATE
[inaudible] THREE THAT WOULD BE --
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN S. C. R..%
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ON HERE TO
PRESENT A C. R. THIRTY ONE WHICH
WOULD HONOR WILLIE BROWN BY
NAMING THE PUBLIC STREET.
CIRCLE IN POSIT NINE FOURTEEN
AND NINE FIFTEEN CAPITAL MALL AS
WILLIE L. BROWN JUNIOR CIRCLE
AND PLAZA AS WE ALL KNOW MISTER
BROWN'S BY ONE OF THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL -- ELECTED OFFICIALS
ARE IN THE STATE IN IN THIS
NATION AND HAS BEEN CENTER
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT.
LIFE FOR ASTOUNDING NOW FOR
DECADES IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
MISTER BROWN MADE HISTORY BY
BECOMING THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN SPEAKERS ASSEMBLY A
ROLE THAT HE HELD FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS DURING HIS TENURE AS AN
ELECTED MEMBER OF THIS.
LEGISLATIVE BODY AND MISTER
BROWN.
LEFT HIS IMPRINT ON EVERY ASPECT
OF PUBLIC POLICY IMPACTING OF
THIS GREAT STATE.
FROM PUBLIC SAFETY CIVIL RIGHTS
WOMEN'S RIGHTS LGBT RIGHTS
EDUCATION ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
HEALTH CARE.
AS WELL AS OUR OUR TREATING --
NINE REPRESENTS THELARA
REPRESENTATIVE -- EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTED UNIONS SPECIFICALLY
HIS EFFORTS RESULT IN
LEGISLATION TO BAN SEMI
AUTOMATIC WEAPONS.
GAINES STATE.
DIVEST MET IN SOUTH AFRICA AND
CREATED STABILITY AND EDUCATION
SYSTEM TO SCHOOL FINANCE REFORM
ACT FOLLOWING HAS A MONUMENTAL
ROLE AS SPEAKER HE WAS ELECTED
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO -- AND HAD A GREAT
IMPACTS DAIRY REFURBISHED AND
REBUILT CALIFORNIA'S BUSIEST
TRANSIT SYSTEM BAR NEARED THE
USE OF BOND MEASURES TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CREATED.
MODEL JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
THIS SINCE THESE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
ARE JUST A BRIEF GLIMPSE OF THE
VARIETY OF BEFORE THINKING A
PROGRESSIVE POLICY THE IDEALS
THAT ARE.
UNDER MISTER BROWN'S LEADERSHIP
AS ARE THIRTY ONE CELEBRATE CELS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS WELL AS
MISTER BROWN'S UNRELENTING
DEDICATION TO A BETTER
CALIFORNIA FALLER EXPECT WITHOUT
FEAR I DID VOTE AND WISHED ME
TODAY IS JOSH PAUL NAY AS WELL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH PANAY
ON BEHALF OF MY WIFE AND I DONNA.
WE'VE KNOWN -- THE FORMER
SPEAKER AND MAYOR FOR THE LAST.
FORTY FIVE YEARS AND WISH TO ADD
OR SUPPORT -- ALTHOUGH THE
ANALYSIS US AND SHOW SUPPORT --
I'VE TALKED TO THE MAYOR OF
SACRAMENTO DARRELL STEINBERG.
FIVE FOUR OTHER MEMBERS OF
COUNCIL WHO WERE IN SUPPORT --
MISTER CARR COUNCILMAN CAR --
COUNCILMAN ALLEN WARREN --
COUNTS MAGICIAN NEAR A
COUNCILMAN HANSON ALL IN SUPPORT
AND A VARIETY OF OTHERS AROUND
THE CAPITAL COMMUNITY.
WHO ALL GET YOU A LIST OF THOSE --
BUT YOU'LL SEE THOSE FOLKS AND
YOU'LL KNOW THOSE NAMES ALL
FOLKS AROUND I SACRAMENTO IN THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY SO I URGE YOUR
I VOTE FOR THIS -- SIMPLE --
RECOGNITION OF THE FORMER
SPEAKER THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IN A IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANY COMMENTS [inaudible]
CENTER.
I'D LIKE TO COMMENT -- CENTER I
WANT I'M HOPING THAT YOU PUT
TOGETHER AND I CEREMONY RIBBON
CUTTING.
IT WHEN THAT SIGN GOES UP
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S SO
DESERVING AND I HAVE -- JIVE.
THAT ARE WILK.
SO I'M PREPARED TO BRED TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY BUT SERIOUSLY
A CIRCLE.
I MEAN IF YOU WERE GONNA NAME AT
THE GYM AT THE JAMES OBERNOLTE
CIRCLE.
THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE BUT BUT
WILLIE BROWN SAID SO MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WE COULDN'T FIND
ANYTHING BETTER TO HONOR HIM
THEN THE CIRCLE.
THAT'S A THAT'S A GOOD POINT
WANT TO CHANGE OLD STREET.
SURE.
SURE WHY NOT.
LEE L. BROWN.
I LIKE THAT I LIKE THAT.
SENATOR HILL -- DID POINT OUT
THAT THERE IS LIKE THE WILLIAM
RIDGE ROW BRIGHT I VOTED FOR
THAT YOU CARE THAT WHEN WE ARE
IN THE FAMILY TOGETHER KERRY BUT
I WROTE FOR OKAY.
HOW COME YOU DIDN'T CARRY IT
[inaudible]
CARRIED IT.
I DON'T REMEMBER.
ALL RIGHT THE TRIVIA KEEP GAME
IS OVER.
UNLESS CENTER PORTANTINO I WAS
JUST SAYING I THOUGHT WE WERE
SAVING ELSTREE TO NAME IT AFTER
SCOTT WELL.
NO OKAY SO I I HAVE FOUND OUT
THAT FORMER CHAIR -- STE IS IT
OR HALL SPONSORED THAT BILL.
SO THAT'S WHY YOU LAST.
WE ALL LOOK ALIKE UP -- WELL WE
DO NOT HAVE A YET A QUORUM --
SENT HER BUT I'M SURE -- WE WILL
LOOK FAVORABLY ON THIS BILL ASKS
THAT WHEN WE DO GET THE ****.
THANK YOU.
AND I HOPE THE AUDIENCES BEEN
ENTERTAIN HERE.
CENTER HER TADO UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE HERE.
YOU'VE GOT -- SENATE BILL FIVE A
ONE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN GOOD MORNING SENATOR.
GOOD MORNING THIS MORNING GOOD
GOOD THANK YOU.
OKAY.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START-OFF BY SUBPOENA COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OFFERED -- BY THE
COMMITTEE WHICH WOULD AMEND THE
BILL TO CLARIFY THAT THE RIDLEY
ARMORIES NOW ELIGIBLE FOR SALE.
I ALSO LIKE TO THANK OUR CHAIR
AND FELIPE LOPEZ WITH THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH OUR
OFFICE ON THESE IMPORTANT
AMENDMENTS.
A SENATE BILL FIVE ALL ONE WILL
HELP A SMALL COMMUNITY IN THE
SOUTHERN CENTRAL VALLEY RETAIN
AN ARMORY THAT WILL HELP SERVE
OUR VETERANS IN THE REGION.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
RIDLEY AREA VETERANS HAVE
OPERATED THE ARMORY FOR VARIOUS
EVENTS INCLUDING VETERAN
SERVICES.
THE READ LEE AREA VETERANS WORK
TO HELP RETURNING VETERANS WHO
ARE STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
THROUGH RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
OR WORKING WITH FOUNDATIONS THE
LIKE THE JOE LUSK MEMORIAL
FOUNDATION TO PER RIGHT TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES FOOD AND
ASSISTANCE WITH MEDICAL COSTS TO
VETERANS.
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE CITY OF RIDLEY AS INVESTED
IN MAKING SURE THAT THE ARMORY
STAYS IN THE COMMUNITY FOR
PURPOSES OF SERVING OUR VETERANS.
AND ALREADY WORKS TO MAINTAIN
THE ARMORY INCLUDING THE LAWN
AND LANDSCAPING AND WORKS WITH
NONPROFIT ENTITIES TO ENSURE
VETERANS SERVICES ACCESSIBLE TO
VETERANS IN THE REGION.
HOWEVER AS A RIDLEY ARMORY WAS
AUTHORIZED FOR SALE BY THE BY
LAST YEAR'S COMMITTEE BILL AB.
THREE TWO FIVE ONE THE CITY OF
RIDLEY HAS BEEN WORKING WITH THE
STATE TO TRY TO KEEP THE ARMY
NOW THAT IT HAS BEEN.
UP FOR SALE.
THE WRIGLEY ARMORY SERVES AS A
CRITICAL ACCESS POINT FOR
VETERANS AND RIDLEY AND
SURROUNDING REGION.
WHO OFTEN HAVE TO DIFFICULTY
ACCESSING YOUR AMERICAN LEGION
POSTER NEARBY VETERANS ARE BEING
ORGANIZATIONS? FOR EXAMPLE THE
NEAREST VETERANS MEMORIAL
DISTRICT IS IN CLOVIS OVER TWO
HOURS AWAY BY PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
AND FORTY MINUTES AWAY BY CAR.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED SB
FIVE A ONE WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
OUR LOCAL.
THERE ARE RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
VETERANS ALSO HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE CRITICAL SERVICES BY
CLARIFYING CLARIFYING THAT THE
ARMORY IS NOT -- ELIGIBLE FOR
CELL AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
AND WITH ME TODAY I HAVE PAUL
MELIKIAN REPRESENTING THE CITY
OF RIDLEY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR --
HER TADO.
THOSE AYE COMMENTS WE WE
ABSOLUTELY -- SUPPORT THOSE
COMMENTS.
THE CITY OF RIDLEY IS A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY WITH
POCKETS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
CLASSIFIED AS SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED AND FOR OVER A
DECADE THE READ LEE AREA
VETERANS HAVE SIX SUCCESSFULLY
OPERATED THE THE ARMORY AS A
REGIONAL -- FACILITY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF VETERANS OF ALL
BRANCHES OF THE MILITARY.
THE FACILITY IS WELL USED BY
VETERANS -- BETTER BOTH IN THE
CITY AND IN THE ENTIRE REGION
THAT ACTUALLY -- PART WORLD WAR
TWO VETERANS KOREA VIETNAM AS
AND TO THE MORE RECENT WARS AND
ENGAGEMENT -- IN THE MIDDLE EAST
THIS IS A TRULY MULTI
GENERATIONAL ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
CREATED A STRONG SUPPORT NETWORK
FOR THOSE RECENT VETERANS THAT
ARE TRANSITIONING BACK INTO
CIVILIAN LIFE.
AND AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
GREATEST.
DIED THE GREATEST GENERATION TO
GIVE BACK IN WAYS THAT THEY
SIMPLY WOULD NOT HAVE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
THE ARMORY -- THE CITY IS A
GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED WORLD
COMMUNITY WITH AS THE AS A
SENATOR SPOKE IS AT THE ACCESS
TO SERVICES FOR THE ECONOMICALLY
OR MOBILITY CHALLENGED ARE
SOMETIMES SEVERAL HOURS -- WAY
AND RECOGNIZING THIS NEED THE
READ LEE AREA VETERANS FORMED A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WHOSE
SOLE MISSION IT IS TO OPERATE
THE THE FOR THE ARMORY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF VETERANS UP ALL
BRANCHES OF THE MILITARY. ONE
SUCH IMPORTANT ACTIVITY IS --
HOSTING REGULAR RESOURCE FAIRS
TO CONNECT VETERANS TO CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE SERVICES IN THEIR
LIVES ESPECIALLY THOSE
TRANSITIONING BACK IN THOSE TO
CIVILIAN LIFE.
THE CITY. FOR THE RIDLEY AREA
VETERAN SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE THE
FUNDING AT THIS TIME TO PURCHASE
THE FACILITY OUT RIGHT HOWEVER
OUR LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE
UNEQUIVOCALLY FEEL THAT SELLING
TO THE HIGHEST BIDDER.
WHICH SERVE TO DESTABILIZE THE
VETERANS AND THE IMPORTANT WORK
THAT IS OCCURRING AT THE
FACILITY I PERSONALLY HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER THAT WAS STATIONED
AT THE ATTHE ARMORY IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES AND CAN ATTEST
THAT THERE IS A VERY STRONG
EMOTIONAL ATTACHMENT TO THIS
REGIONAL -- FACILITY AT THAT AND
AND WHAT IT STANDS FOR IN THE
ENTIRE REGION WE IMPLORE YOU TO
PLEASE ALLOW THE RIDLEY AREA
VETERANS WHO HAVE SERVED THIS
COUNTRY AND PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
WORLD IN THEIR DARKEST HOURS. TO
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE A PLACE TO
ASSEMBLE A PLACE TO VOLUNTEER A
PLACE TO SERVE ONE ANOTHER AND
TO REMAIN A BEACON IN THIS CAN
THIS SIDE COMMUNITY -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU -- ANYBODY
ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS CENTER
ARCHULETA.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR
AGAIN FOR STANDING UP FOR HER
COMMUNITY.
IN THE CERTAINLY THE VETERANS
AND IS WHEN IT BECAME -- WHEN IT
VIA THE BILL BECAME BEFORE OF
THE VETERANS COMMITTEE MY
CONCERN IS THAT IT WOULD ALWAYS
BE USE FOR VETERANS?
ALL BRANCHES NOT GIVEN TO ONE
PARTICULAR UNIT LIKE VFW
AMERICAN LEGION -- AMVETS ANYONE
BUT JUST GENERALLY USED BY ALL
BETTER AND AND UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF THE CITY.
AND FOR MAINTENANCE AND CARE AND
THE END OF THE MANAGEMENT.
AND THAT WAS ONE OF THE THE THE
CONDITIONS.
THE OTHER OF WHICH ARE ANY LAST
MINUTE -- AMENDMENTS FROM A FEW
HOURS AGO TO NOW IN REFERENCE TO
A LEASE PURCHASE.
A NON PURCHASE AND IT WAS THERE
ANY AMENDMENTS THAT THE THREE
MEN.
OF THE OTHER THE THE ONE
AMENDMENT -- IS A IT IMMENSE --
FIVE OH ONE THAT WILL DELETE
CURRENT CONTENTS THE BILL
INSTEAD WOULD REMOVE THE CURRENT
AUTHORIZATION TO SELL.
THE THE THE ARMORY.
AND SO -- I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR TAKING -- THOSE
AMENDMENTS THAT ALLOWS US TO
STAY CONSISTENT WITH OUR
POLICIES.
THAT WE'VE HAD THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ON THE SALE OF STATE
PROPERTY.
EVERYBODY IS BEING TREATED
EXACTLY THE SAME BUT I THINK
ULTIMATELY YOUR END GAME HERE IS --
YEAH OUT.
REALLY STRONG AND WE SUPPORT
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL IN URGENT AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
WELL SENATOR WE STILL DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM WHAT'S ONE OF THE
NEGATIVE THINGS ABOUT HAVING
SUCH A BIG -- COMMITTEE.
YOU JUST NEED TO HAVE A THING
WHAT WE NEED TO HAVE A MEMBERS
HERE NINE MEMBERS. NINE MEMBERS
IN THE ROOM AT THE SAME TIME --
TO GET A QUORUM SO I APPRECIATED
THIS -- BILL WITH A MAMMOTH WILL --
ENJOYED TO PASS --
RECOMMENDATIONS SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
SENATOR BATES.
MONA.
THIS IS -- ITEM NUMBER FIVE SP
.
FOUR SIXTY FIVE A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THEM.
2% THE SB HORSE MY NUMBERS YOU
GUYS. FOR SIXTY FIVE YOU KNOW
HOW IT IS WE DON'T REMEMBER BILL
NUMBERS ONLY ARE SUBJECT -- IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON SHUT DOWN THE
REMAINING TWO UNITS THAT SERRANO
FREE NUCLEAR GENERATING STATION
ALSO KNOWN AS SONGS WITH THE
CLOSURE OF THEIR UNITS THEY HAVE
MADE THE DECISION TO COMMENCE
THE NUCLEAR DECOMMISSIONING
PROCESS.
WHILE FINANCES OPERATIONAL ON
EDISON WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING LOCAL AGENCIES WITH
THE NUCLEAR POWER PREPAREDNESS
FUNDS.
THESE FUNDS WERE USED BY
COUNTIES AND CITIES TO PLAN AND
PREPARE DRILL IN RESPOND TO ANY
EMERGENCY INCIDENTS REGARDING
THE NUCLEAR SITES.
THE COMMISSION PLANTS ARE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING SUCH
FUNDING EVEN THOUGH THAT RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH STORED NUCLEAR
FUEL REMAINS.
SB FOR SIXTY FIVE MAKES IT CLEAR
IN STATUTE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE FUNDING FOR COSTS
INCURRED.
AS A RESULT OF CARRYING OUT
ACTIVITIES THAT ENSURE THE
SAFETY AND WELFARE OF THE
COMMUNITY SURROUNDING SONGS.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN EDISON IN THE
COUNTIES.
ENTERED INTO A SEVEN YEAR
NUCLEAR FUNDING AGREEMENT WHICH
CONTINUE CONTINUED EMERGENCY
PLANNING AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
CAPABILITY RELATED TO SONGS THIS
AGREEMENT MAINTAIN FUNDING AT A
100% UNTIL.
TWENTY NINETEEN BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FUNDING WOULD GO
AYE DOWN FIRST 275% IN AND 50%
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO UNDER THIS
PREVIOUS AGREEMENT THE SIGNATORY
PARTIES WOULD RECONVENE TO
NEGOTIATE A SUCCESSOR AGREEMENT
WHEN SONGS IMPLEMENTED THE NEXT
PHASE OF THEIR NUCLEAR EMERGENCY
PLAN.
HERE TO GIVE MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION ABOUT THE CURRENT
STATUS OF THE SUCCESSOR ABLE YOU.
IS DONNA BOSTON WITH THE ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
JONATHAN CLAY ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO.
DONNA.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD -- SB FOR
SIXTY FIVE IS THE SOLUTION TO
THE LEGISLATIVE GAP IN FUNDING
FOR LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES
THAT HAS RESULTED FROM AS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
SENATE -- FREE NUCLEAR.
STATION DE COMMISSIONING.
DECOMMISSIONING PROCESS
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED ON SITE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPABILITIES.
AND LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES
MAINTAIN THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
RESPOND TO ANY EMERGENCY AT SAN
ONOFRE NUCLEAR GENERATING
STATION.
AND COORDINATE WITH THE SAN
ONOFRE NUCLEAR GENERATING
STATION IN THAT RESPONSE.
COMMUNITY CONCERN HAS REMAINED A
CONSTANT HIGH LEVEL PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES HAVE DOCUMENTED
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR RESPONDING
ON SITE.
SENATE -- FREE NUCLEAR
GENERATING STATIONS PERMANENTLY
DE FIELD EMERGENCY PLAN LISTS
OFF SITE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
AGENCIES ARE.
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES AS THOSE
THAT WILL RESPOND TO EMERGENCY
PROVIDE NOTIFICATION TO OTHER
EMERGENCY RESPONSE ORGANIZATIONS.
SENATE OF FREE MAINTAINS AN A
SITE SPECIFIC LAW ENFORCEMENT
EMERGENCY RSPONSE PLAN IN WHICH
OUR LOCAL EMERGENCY RESPONDERS.
OUR FIRST IN FOR EMERGENCIES AT
THE PLANTS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE PROVIDED WITH TRAINING IN
THE TOOLS IN ADVANCE OF THOSE
INCIDENTS.
ALL FIRST RESPONDERS MUST BE
PROVIDED WITH THE RIGHT
EQUIPMENT THE TRAINING AND
MONITORING TO ENSURE THEIR
SAFETY.
WHILE THEY ACT TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITY.
THE RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DECOMMISSIONING AT A NUCLEAR
PLANT STILL EXISTS.
WITHIN THE SITUATION AT SEVEN OH
FREE.
AN PASSED DOCUMENTED
COMPLICATIONS THERE IS A
DEMONSTRATED NEED TO CONTINUE
THE CURRENT EMERGENCY RESPONSE
CAPABILITY.
SB FOUR SIXTY FIVE RESOLVES THE
ISSUE OF CONTINUAL NEGOTIATIONS
FOR ALL PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES.
BY RETURNING TO THEIR ORIGINAL
FORMAT FOR FUNDING.
THE FUNDING WILL PASS THROUGH
THE STATE AND ENDS. FOR THE
ORIGINATES THE UTILITY IT PASSES
THROUGH IS THAT THROUGH THE
STATE AND ENDS WITH THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES.
AS BEFORE SIXTY FIVE PREVENTS
TAXPAYERS FROM HAVING TO
SUBSIDIZE THE DECOMMISSIONING.
OF AN INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY.
AND ENSURES THE CONTINUATION OF
THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
CAPABILITY.
THE COUNTIES OF ORANGE AND SAN
DIEGO TOGETHER WITH THE CITIES
OF SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO DANA
POINT IN SAN CLEMENTE.
WORK COLLABORATIVELY CREEK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE SENATE
FREE NUCLEAR GENERATING STATION
TO ENSURE OUR COMMUNITY RECEIVES
THE BEST SERVICE AND HAS THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSE CAPABILITY.
REDUCING THIS COORDINATION OR
CAPABILITY IS NOT IN THE
INTEREST OF PUBLIC SAFETY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOU.
JONATHAN CLAN BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY COVERED ALL
THE MAIN POINTS I JUST WANT TO
REINFORCE -- COUPLE THINGS THAT
THE RADIATION PROTECTION ACT IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE REQUIRES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE
THESE COMMUNITY PLANNING AND
SERVICES TO HELP PROTECT OUR
CITIZENS IN THE CASE OF
EMERGENCY -- WITH THIS THE
COMMISSION PROCESS WE STILL HAVE
RADIOACTIVE MATERIAL IT'S GOING
TO BE ON SITE FOR AWHILE.
THERE ARE STILL CONCERNS WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE ELECTED
BORDERS OFFICIALS HERE ABOUT
THIS.
SO WE STILL FEEL THE NEED TO
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY PLANNING WHILE THAT
MATERIAL STILL THERE.
IN SHORT AS BEFORE SIX FIVE
WOULD HELP ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING CONTINUES ON TO COULD
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE DOING THE
WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS A SPORT.
HI MANUAL CAMARGO DONE.
NOT -- DON'T HAVE OFFICIAL
POSITION HERE WITH A AS HE THANK
YOU.
THE OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
DID WITH HER.
DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK YES PLEASE.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN BY MAY YES --
YES SO A GOOD MORNING HEY I WANT
TO SAY LET ME JUST DO THIS THE
THE PROPER WAY ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IN YOUR TO YOUR TWEENER YES OKAY
WHAT YOU GO NOW.
THANK YOU PROCEED THAT MY
PLEASURE MORNING.
MY NAME IS MANAL CAMARGO AND
WORK FOR ITS C. E. IS PRINCIPLE
MANAGERS TO GIGI PLANNING FOR
SONGS -- WHILE -- AS HE DOES NOT
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THIS BILL I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE WITH RESPECT AS BEFORE.
SIXTY FIVE AS REFERENCED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND IS
DISCUSSED HERE THIS MORNING AS
HE HAS AN M. O. U. IN PLACE
TODAY.
BUT WITHORANGE AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES AS WELL AS THE CITIES
OF SANTA MANY SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO DANA POINT -- TO
MAINTAIN FUNDING LEVELS THAT
REFLECT THE SCALE DOWN RISK WITH
SONGS.
YES HE IS ALWAYS BEEN COMMITTED
TO PROVIDING CONTINUED FUNDING
FOR OFF SITE LOCAL AGENCIES.
HOWEVER IF THE AS HE DOES
BELIEVE THAT THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING FOR OFFSET AGENCIES
SHOULD BE INFORMED BY THE LEVEL
OF RISK WHICH ALREADY IS GREATLY
REDUCED -- DUE TO THE NUCLEAR
REACTORS BEING PERMANENTLY DE
FUELED.
IN SIMPLE TERMS THIS MEANS IS
SONGS NO LONGER IS AT RISK OF A
NUCLEAR MELTDOWN FOR INSTANCE --
IN THE REACTORS.
IT'S FURTHER MILESTONES IN
DECOMMISSIONING OR ACHIEVED --
THE RISK IT SONGS WILL CONTINUE
TO STEP DOWN -- INTEL SONGS IS
FULLY DECOMMISSIONED.
ALREADY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ITSELF.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FEMA
THERE IN THIS YEAR OF MADE --
REDUCTIONS IN EMERGENCY STAFFING
TO ALIGN WITH THE WITH THE
REDUCE RISK AND AS PURSUANT TO
U. S. NUCLEAR REGULATORY
COMMISSION REGULATIONS.
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
THE AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE HAS
GRANTED IS HERE TODAY -- TO
DISCUSS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
RELATED TO SONGS AND THE RISK
BASED APPROACH TO OFFSITE
EMERGENCY PLANNING FUNDS THAT AS
HE PREFERS.
AS WE HAVE IN THE PAST IS THE E.
REMAINS COMMITTED. TO THE AUTHOR
THE LEGISLATURE LOCAL OFFICIALS
IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE%
TO HELP FACILITATE THE SAFE
DECOMMISSIONING OF SONGS.
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE S. EASE PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS BILL.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE.
THEY CRIED FOR TEST MY YOU
ANSWERED A FEW OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT I HAD SO I APPRECIATED VERY
MUCH ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. TO
THIS BILL.
SEE NOW I'LL TURN BACK -- TO THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
TREATMENT.
CENTER WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
YET WE'RE WORKING ON THAT -- WE
NEED TO TO SLOWLY US.
WE NEED TO MORE BUT I APPRECIATE --
OF THE TESTIMONY HERE TODAY PER
SHEET THIS BILL IT WILL HAVE A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR APPRECIATE
THAT AND ALL OF THE BILL WILL
HELP BY.
THE THE DISCUSSIONS TO CONTINUE
BETWEEN L. C. E. AND THE
AFFECTED PARTIES AND I'M SURE
THAT THEYARE GETTING CLOSE TO A
RESOLUTION US ALL ABOUT FINDING
OUR EQUALS RISK RISKY BECAUSE
FUNDING AND SO OF THE THIS WILL
HELP.
I THINK PUSH IT ALONG BECAUSE
THEY THEY NEEDED A LITTLE MORE --
ENERGY AND IN THEIR DISCUSSIONS
HAVE BEEN GOING ON FOR QUITE
AWHILE AND THERE'S NO CONCLUSION
YET BUT I THINK WE'RE GETTING
CLOSE THANK YOU RIGHT RETREAT
THAT MUCH.
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE HERE
BESIDES ME.
SHOULD I JUST [inaudible]
GLAZER.
GOOD MORNING WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL WE'VE GOT TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORNING.
LET ME CREATE SOME CONTEXT FOR
THIS SIDE THIS BILL.
I TO DISTRICT BILL FOR ME.
I HAVE IN MY DISTRICT IN OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE PARK.
NOTHING IN THE END THIS BILL
CHANGES THAT.
THEY ARE.
SPACE THAT -- MANY USED TO ENJOY
THAT ACTIVITY IF YOU LIKE IT
SOME PEOPLE LIKE IT SOME PEOPLE
DON'T.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL AFFECTS
THAT EXISTING PARK THERE ARE TOO
MANY IN THE STATE BUT I HAVE.
ONE THERE'S A EXPANSION PROPOSAL
TO THIS PARK.
REFERRED TO ASSESS Là.
THE PARKS DEPARTMENT BOUGHT THE
PROPERTY [inaudible]
A COUPLE [inaudible]
DECADES AGO -- AND THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING TO TRY TO CREATE AN
EXPANSION OF THAT PARK.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL CHANGES
THAT PROCESS.
THE LAND'S BEEN PURCHASED
THEY'RE GOING TO THE PROCESS OF
TRYING TO DEVELOP IT.
AND MY LEGISLATION DOESN'T
CHANGE THAT AT ALL.
BUT THIS LAND FOR THIS EXPANSION
HAS A LOT OF DIFFERENT OPINIONS
ABOUT IT.
AT THE SENSITIVE PARCEL OF LAND
I'M GONNA HAVE SOME WONDERFUL
WITNESSES WILL TALK ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SENSITIVITY.
ABOUT IT.
BUT WHAT THIS LEGISLATION DOES
AND WHAT IT ONLY DOES.
IS THAT IF THE PARKS DEPARTMENT
AND THE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
COMMISSION.
DECIDES THAT THIS EXPANSION AT
THIRD THAT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR A
LONG LONG TIME IS IN LITIGATION
AFTER LITIGATION AFTER
LITIGATION IF THEY DECIDE.
THAT THIS IS NOT GONNA WORK WE
HAVE AN EXISTING PARK WE'RE NOT
GOING TO CHANGE THAT BUT THIS
EXPANSION IS TOO CONTROVERSIAL.
THIS LEGISLATION GIVES THEM THE
CHANCE TO HAVE A CHOICE TO TRY
TO GET THEIR MONEY BACK.
THAT'S IT.
GIVES THEM THE OPTION.
HI THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE THAT I
RAN ON IN MY CAMPAIGN I TOOK NO
POSITION ON UNTIL I COULD
RESEARCH IT CAREFULLY AND
THOUGHTFULLY.
AND I DID.
ALONG WITH THIS FAMILY WOMAN
CATHERINE BAKER THE REPUBLICAN --
WHO USED TO REPRESENT THIS AREA?
AND AFTER ALL THAT WORK THAT WE
DID TO KEEP IT HERE FROM ALL
SIDES OF THE ISSUE WE CAME TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT THERE SHOULD
AT LEAST BE AN OPTION.
IF THIS LITIGATION AND THIS
CONTROVERSY'S GOING NO WHERE TO
HAVE AN OPTION TO GET THEIR
MONEY BACK INTO THE OFF HIGHWAY
FUND.
pTO ENHANCE THAT ACTIVITY IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE OR EVEN
NEARBY. SIXTEEN LEGISLATORS
SENATORS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
JOIN WITH US LAST YEAR IN
ENCOURAGING THE PARKS DEPARTMENT
TO PURSUE THIS OPTION.
THEIR ANSWER IS WE CAN'T DO IT
LEGALLY WE NEED A BILL TO GIVE
US THAT RIGHT IF WE EVER CHOSE
TO HAVE THAT RIGHT AND THAT'S
WHAT'S -- BEFORE YOU.
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR FROM MY
WITNESSES ABOUT THE VALUE OF THE
LAND NEXT DOOR THIS BILL COULD
PROTECT.
BUT I WANT TO JUST ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS THAT YOU'LL
ALSO HEAR IN A MOMENT.
THEY MAKE THE ASSERTION THAT
THIS LEGISLATION FORCES A SALE
FORCES NOT.
THIS BILL DOESN'T FORCE ANYTHING.
THE ONLY WAY THISBILL GOES INTO
OPERATION IT TO THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT AND THE OFF HIGHWAY.
VEHICLE COMMISSION WHICH IS MADE
UP OF ENTHUSIASTS FOR OFF
HIGHWAY SAY YOU KNOW WHAT.
IF WE CAN GET OUR MONEY BACK.
THAT MIGHT BE THE BEST COURSE
FOR TRYING.
TO ENCOURAGE THAT ACTIVITY IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE OR EVEN
NEARBY SO THAT MY FRIENDS IS
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT. TO
DISTRICT BILL I HAVE SOME
WONDERFUL WITNESSES TALK ABOUT
THE ISSUE MORE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
SENATOR.
HI -- CATHERINE PHILLIPS WITH
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA -- WE
HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS STATEWIDE AND
THEY INCLUDE ACTIVE MEMBERS AND
VOLUNTEERS IN THE AREA WHERE
THIS PARK.
EXISTS IN WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING
FOR NEARLY TWENTY YEARS TO HAVE
IT PRESERVED AS A PARK A PASSIVE
PARK -- OUR LOCAL SIERRA CLUB
CHAPTER IS PART OF THE ALTAMONT.
LANDFILL OPEN SPACE COMMITTEE
THAT'S RESPONSIBLE FOR EXPANDING
LOCAL OPEN SPACE MITIGATION
FUNDS IN THAT HAS OFFERED TO USE
ITS LOCAL FUNDS TO PURCHASE THE
ALAMEDA TESLA EXPANSION AREA --
WE CARE ABOUT THIS LAND SO MUCH
BECAUSE SIMPLY IT IS A STUNNING
BIODIVERSITY HOT SPOT THE MOIST
COAST RANGE MEETS THE NORTH EDGE
OF THE DRY SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY IN
JUST CREATES A VERY UNUSUAL.
HABITAT -- IT'S GENERALLY
DESCRIBED AS BLUE OAK WOODLAND
AND GRASSLAND BUT THAT DOESN'T
DO THE PLACE JUSTICE IT'S UNLIKE
OTHER WOODLANDS AND GRASSLANDS
IN THE REGION BECAUSE OF ITS
BIODIVERSITY RICHNESS BECAUSE IT
BRINGS TOGETHER ESSENTIALLY.
FIVE SORT OF ECO SYSTEMS.
AND ONE OF THOSE THE IT'S IT'S
DRAWN LEADING NATURALISTS FOR
MORE THAN A HUNDRED YEARS
INCLUDING -- JOHN ME OR WHO WAS
THE FOUNDER OF SIERRA CLUB AND
THE FATHER OF THE NATIONAL PARK
SYSTEM -- THE SCIENTISTS
CONSENSUS STATEMENT ON
ECOLOGICAL VALUE OF THE ALAMEDA
TESLA EXPANSIONARY WAS SIGNED BY
FORTY FIVE SCIENTISTS INCLUDING.
LEADING PROFESSORS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF SCIENCES --
IT HAS FORTY TWO SPECIAL STATUS
WILDLIFE SPECIES INCLUDING EIGHT
FEDERALLY OR STATE LISTED IN
CANDIDATES SPECIES.
AND I COULD GO ON WITH LOTS OF
DETAILS ABOUT THE ECOLOGICAL AND
NATURAL RESOURCE VALUE -- BUT
SUFFICE IT TO SAY IT'S A VERY
SPECIAL PLACE AND THIS BILL
FOCUSES ON A SPECIFIC LOCAL
ISSUE AS THE AUTHOR NOTED.
THAT WILL PROVIDE BOTH OF WHY
HE'S OF USE OF OF A RESOLUTION
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AND WILL BE
FAIR TO STATE PARKS AND TO THE
DIVISION.
OF OFF HIGHWAY MOTOR VEHICLE
RECREATION -- BUT IT HAS
STATEWIDE IMPORTANCE BECAUSE
AGAIN THIS PLACE IS -- IS A AN
ECOLOGICALLY VALUABLE PLACE THAT
AGAIN HAS BEEN THE SOURCE OR THE
THE SUBJECT OF LOTS OF STUDY FOR
GENERATIONS -- THIS AREA JUST
SCREAMS FOR GOOD RESPONSIBLE
STEWARDSHIP AND THE BACK THIS
BILL WILL OPEN A PATHWAY TO
PROVIDE THAT KIND OF STEWARDSHIP
THAT IT WARRANTS SO I URGE THAT
YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
MORNING MY NAME IS NANCY
RHETORIC I'M FROM LIVERMORE.
AND I'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF
FRIENDS ATTESA PARK AND I HAVE
BEEN FOR THE LAST EIGHT YEARS --
I'M VERY ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT
PRESERVING THIS LAND BECAUSE
I'VE ACTUALLY HIKES ON IT.
SO AND THAT'S HOW I GOT INVOLVED --
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OTHER
ITEMS -- THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY THE O. H. P. DIVISION. SIX SO --
SB SIX SEVEN SIX SEVEN IS A
LOCAL MEASURE.
ALL OF THE ALAMEDA TESLA
EXPANSION AREA IS LOCATED IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
THERE'S OVERWHELMING LOCAL
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. SIX
PUBLIC AGENCIES INCLUDING THE
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA AND AT THE
CITY OF LIVERMORE.
ARE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THE LOCAL OPEN SPACE FUND HAS
OFFERED THE MONEY FOR THE
PURCHASE OF TESLA.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVEN SIX SEVEN
DOES NOT TAKE AWAY ANY OF THE
EXISTING CARNEGIE ALWAYS BE
WRITING AREAS.
STATE PARKS DID NOT COMPLETE AN
ACQUISITION E. I. R. PRIOR TO
THE PURCHASE OF THE EXPANSION
AREA.
SO PUBLIC NOTICE DID NOT OCCUR
UNTIL AFTER THE LAND WAS ALREADY
PURCHASED IN.
TWO THOUSAND SB TWO FORTY NINE
LAST YEAR DID NOT ADDRESS TESLA.
PRESERVATION.
BUT IF TWO FOR TWO FOR FOUR NINE
WERE FOLLOWED TUSSLE WOULD NEVER
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED -- FOR EACH
P. RECREATION.
ALMOST THE ENTIRE AREA WE SHOULD
INSTEAD BE DESIGNATED AS A
SENSITIVE AREA AND PROTECTED BY
STATUTE.
THE EXPANSION AREA IN THE
PROPOSED VOICE HM VIS OUR PLAN
IS ONLY DESIGNATED AS A
MOTORIZED VEHICLE PARK LIKE
CARNEGIE.
NONE OF THE EXPANSION AREA IS
PROTECTED AS A DEFINED SENSITIVE
AREA. SEVEN SIX SEVEN DOES NOT
ESTABLISH ANY STATE WHY
PRESIDENT BUT RATHER IT
ADDRESSES THE SPECIFIC LOCAL
ISSUE WITH THE UNIQUE HISTORY.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
GLAZER AND THE BILL'S MANY CO
SPONSORS. FOR SEEKING A PATH TO
RESOLVE THIS TWENTY YEAR LOCAL
CONTROVERSY IN A WAY THAT IS
WISE AND FAIR.
WE ARE ASKING FOR YOUR YES VOTE.
ON SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
[inaudible]
PLEASE MAKE.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER SPENCE I
REPRESENT THE SOCIETY OF
AMERICAN INDIANS.
AND THE CONFEDERATED VILLAGES
WILL ASSIGN.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN AND OUR
GREATEST CONCERN IS THE
PRESERVATION OF OUR LEGACY OF
THE ANCESTORS AND THE PROTECTION
OF THE ANCIENT SACRED SITES
CEREMONIAL SITES BURIAL SITES
AND ENTER ARTIFACTS [inaudible]
MEL ARE.
IF IF WE LOOK AT THE LEVEL OF
PROTECTION ON THE CURRENT
CARNEGIE SITE.
WE HAVE TO SERIOUSLY QUESTION.
I HOPE THIS EXPANSION --
CARNEGIE HAS MET WITH TRIBES IN
THE PAST AND RELATED TO THESE
CONCERNS AND HAVING NOR THEM.
SIR WE ASK FOR YEARS STRONG
SUPPORT IN THIS BILL AND HELPING
US TO HONOR MOTHER EARTH AND THE
PRESERVATION OF OUR ANCESTORS
LIKE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK SPEAKER.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DICK
RYAN I REPRESENT TO GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS IN LIVERMORE THE
DELIVER MORE HERITAGE SKILLED
AND FRIENDS OF LIVERMORE WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL TO SEND THEIR
GLAZER FOR HIS WIN WIN.
PROPOSAL THAT HE'S MAKING HERE
THAT THAT WILL ALLOW THOSE THIS
IS STATE.
PARKS TO THE OPTION TO TO SELL
THIS PROPERTY. TO TO UP AN
AGENCY WHICH COULD CAN PRESERVE
IT [inaudible]
UP.
SO WE'RE HEY WE'RE REINSTALLED
SUPPORT THE RELIEF VERY THANKFUL
FOR SENATOR GLAZERS AND
INFORMERS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAKER'S EFFORT TO PRESERVE THIS
PARK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING I'M TAMERA ROYCE OF
LIVERMORE AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF FRIENDS OF THE OPEN
SPACE AND VINEYARDS AND ALONG
WITH FRIENDS OF THE ARROYOS AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT -- THIS BILL
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS.
IS AVAILABLE SALAS WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
MR KAREN MEMBERS MONICA MILLER
REPRESENTING THE CAN YOU TELL ME
ABOUT FORTY SUPERVISORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND KATHLEEN GALA GOT
JOHN OF SENATOR GALGIANI AND
SENATOR OF GLACIER.
MY NAME IS KATHERINE PRESS I'M
CHAIRPERSON OF THE NORTHERN
VALLEY YOU'LL CUT BAY MIWOK
ALONI AND ALSO WITH NO TO TELL
ME CULTURE PRESERVATION.
THE SET SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN WILL SUPPORT AND PROTECT
OUR ANCESTRAL GROUNDS OF THE
LOOT TO CHECK TRIED OKAY.
WE HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE AREA
WILL DESTROY NOT ONLY ARE
MEDICINAL MEDICINES THAT WE NEED.
ARE UP PLANTS THERE ARE NATURAL
TO THE AREA THE LANDSCAPE THE
WATER THE CLEAN AIR WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT OUR BURIAL SITES
WILL ALSO BE IMPACTED IN THEIR
FUNERAL OBJECTS.
SO BUT WE STRONGLY SUGGEST THAT
SENATE BILLS SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
BE SUPPORTED THANK YOU.
CHRISTINE CORRAL NOTED COMING UP
[inaudible]
HELLO.
ANYWAY STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M CINDY KENNEDY I MEMBERS
SUPPORT I REPRESENT A TEST LE
ROAD RESIDENTS ALLIANCE IN TRI
VALLEY TRAIL BLAZERS THE
REGIONALLY QUESTION GROUP.
AND I' SUPPORT OF SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF MY NAME IS MARCUS CAREER AND
I'M A REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL
ARCHAEOLOGISTS REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE NORTHERN VALLEY OAK IT'S
TRIBE.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL.
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN ALAMEDA TESLA
EXPANSION AREAS SACRED GROUND TO
THE YOKE IT'S AMY WALK IN A
LONELY PEOPLES AND WE SUPPORT
THE PROTECTION AND PRESERVATION
OF TESLA EXPANSION AREA.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON SB.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS CELESTE GARAMENDI I'M
HERE N BEHALF OF THREE REGIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS IN ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
SAVE MOUNT DIABLO.
AND THE ALONI AND MOUNT DIABLO
AUDUBON SOCIETY'S HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SEVEN SIX SEVEN THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
MORNING.
BUT TERRY MCHALE WITH THEIR IN
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENT A
CONSORTIUM OF OHB.
ASSOCIATIONS INCLUDING A IN A
THIRTY SIX AND THIRTY SEVEN AND
AMERICAN SAND ASSOCIATION.
WE WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL LAST
YEAR WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THIS YEAR.
THE DIFFERENCE HOWEVER IS WE DO
APPRECIATE SENATOR GLAZER DID
MAKE THE PRICING OF LAST YEAR'S
BILL THE FLOOR INSTEAD OF THE
CEILING -- AND SECOND OF ALL WE
APPRECIATE THAT HIS OFFICE IS
BEEN OPEN.
AND WILLING TO DISCUSS SOME KIND
OF SOLUTION.
I'VE LEARNED WITH -- HP THAT
DOING AWAY TO BE ISSUES IS
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN DOING THE DOG
CHASING THE BEAR UP THE TREE AND
VACCINATIONS.
I MEAN IT'S VERY VERY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE FULLER ARE SO POLARIZED
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
MY CONCERN WITH THIS BILL BOILS
DOWN TO THIS [inaudible]
NOBODY.
WHO KNOWS SENATOR GLAZER WOULD
BELIEVE THAT HE DOES A BILL THAT
DOESN'T DO SOMETHING OF
SUBSTANCE?
HE'S A QUALITY LEGISLATOR WHO
DOES A GREAT JOB WITH THIS
CONSTITUENTS AND IT'S REFLECTED
IN THE ARTICLE THAT COMES OUT
AFTER THE LAST BILL IN WHICH THE
HEADLINE SAYS.
TESLA PARK SALE APPROVED BY
STATE SENATE COMMITTEE SB SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN A MEASURE THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE STATE TO SELL CARNEGIE
STATE VEHICULAR RECREATION AREA.
FOR CONSERVATION PURPOSES
CLEARED ITS FIRST HEARING.
AND FUNDAMENTALLY THAT'S THE
PROBLEM WITH THE BILL THE BILL
ITSELF.
I AGREE WE NEED A SOLUTION.
WE NEED A SOLUTION BECAUSE IT'S
GONE ON TOO LONG.
HOWEVER THE BILL ONLY GIVES ONE
SOLUTION IT'S SORT OF LIKE THE
JUDGE ROY BEAN THING YOU KNOW
WE'RE GONNA DO A HEARING ON EACH
OF FAIR HEARING ON A WAY TO BE
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA GET RID OF
IT.
THE BILL DOESN'T SAY WHAT
HAPPENS IF WE DO THESE HEARINGS
AND IT TURNS OUT.
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DID
EVERYTHING CORRECTLY.
THIS IS NOT STE LOCAL THIS IS
NOT A LOCAL ISSUE THIS IS AN
AREA IN WHICH MOTORCYCLES WERE
WRITTEN ON IT.
THIS IS AN AREA IN WHICH STATE
PARKS DID PUBLIC HEARINGS.
THIS IS AN ISSUE WHICH THE STATE
PARKS DID EVERYTHING THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO DO TO REACH THE
POINT WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
AND WHAT IF IT TURNS OUT THEY
DID DO EVERYTHING CORRECTLY THEN
THE BILL SHOULD SAY THAT WE WILL
EXPEDITE THE USE OF THIS
PROPERTY -- FOR HD PURPOSES OF
CLOSE BY SAYING THERE TO MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY PARKS.
OF STATE PARKS IN CALIFORNIA
ONLY EIGHT OF THEM.
DEAL WITH OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
RECREATION.
THIS IS AN AREA IN WHICH EVEN
THOSE WHO STAND UP IN OPPOSITION
WERE APPROACHED AND WERE GIVEN
THE ABILITY TO SPEAK ON THIS
ISSUE IN THE PARKS DECIDED.
IT WAS A GOOD IDEA SO I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE REJECT THIS
BILL THANK YOU MR CALE NEXT
SPEAKER [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
ANY GRANTED ON BEHALF OF THE OFF
ROAD VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION I'M ALSO A OFF ROADER
PROUD OFF ROADER.
A GRANDMOTHER IN AN
ARCHAEOLOGICAL SITES STORED FOR
CARNEGIE AND ANY IMPRESSION THAT
HAS BEEN GIVEN THAT THE
ARCHAEOLOGICAL.
SITES IN KEARNEY HAVE NOT BEEN
GIVEN.
PROPER REVIEW AND ARE NOT BEING
PROTECTED I I FIND SOMEWHAT.
IT'S NOT ONLY WRONG BECAUSE I
CAN PERSONALLY ATTEST TO IT IT'S
SORT OF OFFENSIVE TO THINK THAT
WE DON'T.
TAKE EVERY BIT [inaudible]
OF EVERY BIT OF ARCHAEOLOGICAL
SITE IMPORTANT SERIOUSLY WITHIN
THE OFFROAD COMMUNITY WE HAVE
BEEN MMBER MISREPRESENTED OFTEN
THIS BILL IS REALLY PRETTY
SIMPLE IT'S REALLY NO DIFFERENT
THAN A TAKE MILLIONAIRE WHICH
HAS HAPPENED WHO FINDS HIMSELF
NEAR REALLY POPULAR SURFING AREA.
AND SAYS I DON'T WANT THOSE
PEOPLE TRUST PASSING NEAR MY
PROPERTY DOESN'T MATTER THAT IT
STAYED ON PROPERTY OR COUNTY ON
PROPERTY THEY DECIDE IT'S NOT.
A USE THAT HE OR SHE FINDS
ACCEPTABLE IT'S THE SAME THING
THAT WERE FIGHTING HERE IN THIS
BILL IS NOT A LOCAL ISSUE THAT
WOULD SET A PRECEDENT WHERE ANY.
WELL CONNECTED POLITICALLY
CONNECTED LOCALS ELLIS CAN
DECIDE THAT ANY USE OF A
PROPERTY THAT THEY DON'T HAPPEN
TO APPROVAL IT.
CAN BE PUT UP FOR SALE AND COULD
BE PUSHED THROUGH THE SALE BY
ANY.
AGENCY IN THIS CASE IT'S STATE
PARKS -- I WOULD SAY THAT'S A
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THERE ARE ABOUT
EIGHT MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE -- WHICH WE INTO CS AND
THAT'S ACCORDING TO FOREST
SERVICE FIGURES THAT'S A WHOLE
LOT OF US IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR EIGHT OR NINE
EACH BE PARKS.
WE NEED A LEGAL PLACED RIDE BUT
THE DIFFERENCE IN THIS AREA IS
THAT A FULLY THIRD OF THE
HEARING WAS SET ASIDE. FOR
NATURAL RESOURCE CONSERVATION IN
THIS PLAN ANOTHER THING.
ANOTHER.
AREA THAT WAS REALLY FRIENDLY
LOOKED I WAS VERY CLOSE TO MY
HEART WAS DISABLED ACCESS IS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR DISABLED
ACCESS TO HAVE THE SABLE PEOPLE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE OUTDOOR
AND THAT'S ONE THING.
THAT THIS PLAN FULLY ALLOWS FOR
THANK YOU -- OTHER WITNESSES --
OPPOSED PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND BE BRIEF PLEASE GOOD MORNING --
NICHOLAS HARRIS WESTERN STATES
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE AMERICAN
MOTORCYCLIST ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
WELL DONE.
BUT DON AMADOR GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FRAME A DISTRICT THIRTY
SIX AND A MEMBER AND CHAIRMAN OF
THE WHICH BE COMMISSION IN
NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN WE
PURCHASED THE PROPERTY.
MY CONCERN SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
IS IT SETS UP A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT.
WHERE YOU HAVE LOCAL POLITICAL
ACTIVIST SET UP A TWO TIERED
STRATEGY TO CLOSE AT PARK UNIT?
THAT'S THROUGH LITIGATION THE
LEGISLATION.
IS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT FOR ANY
STATE PARK UNIT AND WE'RE
STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION WE ASK
YOU NOT TO SUPPORT THAT BILL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JAMES OF OUR
JUNIOR BEHALF OF A CALIFORNIA
MORE CYCLE RIGHTS AND SAFETY
ORGANIZATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
MOTORCCLE DEALERS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S KEN OR YOUR I'M IN OFF
ROADER IN CORE REMEMBER.
AND I'VE DONE A LOT OF STUDY ON
THIS AND AS LEGISLATORS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE.
THE PREMIUM -- LAND USE AGENCY
AT YOUR HANDS THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT.
THEY WERE CONSULTED WORLDWIDE
AND IN THE UNITED STATES SO WHEN
YOU WANT TO KNOW ABOUT LAND USE
CONSULT YOUR OWN.
YOUR OWN REPRESENTATIVE YOUR OWN
SPECIALISTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M KEN CLARKE.
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA OFF ROAD
VEHICLE SAY SURELY ASSOCIATION
PRESIDENT OF THE WANDERING
WHEELERS JEEP CLUB OF HAYWARD
CALIFORNIA I'M A LOCAL RESIDENT.
I LIVE IN CASTRO VALLEY.
I'M A SENIOR CITIZEN DISABLED
AND A PERSON OF NATIVE AMERICAN
DESCENT.
I KNOW THE STATE PARKS ARE GOING
TO PRESERVE THIS AREA.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS REALLY READ THE
GENERAL PLAN IT'S REALLY GOOD
IT'S A SHARED USE PLANT SO AYE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN NOT
CAPULETS REPRESENTING THE OFF
ROAD VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION.
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL AGAIN THIS ISN'T THE FIRST
BILL THAT I'VE BEEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE ON WHERE STATE
PROPERTY IS BEING -- TAKEN AWAY
BY LOCALS ALL IT'S AND IT'S A
STATE PROPERTY SO IT SEEMS THAT
IT THE TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING FOR
THE WHOLE THING.
THEN THEY OUGHT TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE WHOLE THING AND IF THE
LOCAL ZEALOTS WANT TO DISBAND TO
THEN THEY SHOULD BE PAYING THE
FREIGHT FOR ALL THIS THIS IS.
VERY DANGEROUS PRECEDENT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SHERRI STORE TRON I DON'T
REPRESENT ANYONE I'M JUST IN A
WAY TO BE PERSON.
I WAS A PART OF THE ORIGINAL
USER REPRESENTATIVE GROUP
REPRESENTING FOUR WHEEL DRIVE
INTERESTS BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
SPORT.
SINCE THE LATE EIGHTIES -- I
DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHY WE HAVE TO KEEP RE HASHING
THESE BILLS?
ARE I DO BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
ENOUGH OPEN SPACE I BELIEVE THAT
THE HM VIS OUR DIVISION WILL
PROTECT EVERY SPECK OF THAT LAND
THAT NEEDS TO BE PROTECTED.
AND IT IS SUCH A SMALL PART.
OF CALIFORNIA THAT US AWAY TO BE
PEOPLE GET TO WRECK CREATE ON
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK HAS OVER
A HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND
ACRES NOT ONE MILE DO THEY OFFER.
TO H. B. ACCESS THOUGH OUR TAXES
ALL PAY FOR THAT SO I'M SANE.
OPPOSE SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN THANK
YOU IT IS A BAD BILL EXCEPT AS A
BAD PRECEDENCE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DIANA MEAD.
I AM A PROUD DEMOCRAT.
SENATOR GLAZER IS MY SENATOR
[inaudible]
STATE PARKS.
HAS THE CORNER ON THE MARKET ON
HOW TO TAKE CARE OF PUBLIC LANDS.
AND WE OUGHT TO GIVE THEM THE
CHANCE TO DO WHAT WE'VE
ENTRUSTED THEM TO DO.
AND LET THE SKULL BUT THE SCOUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL COME BACK -- TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
CENTER GLAZER.
DO NOT LEAVE SENATOR ALLEN YOU
KNOW THE I AM SO SERIOUS ABOUT
THIS.
WE NEED ONE MORE MEMBER
SERGEANTS WE GOT TO GET SOMEBODY
IN HERE.
WE WOULD OFFER A QUORUM YES THE
MEETING FOR NOW OR FORTY FIVE
MINUTES BACK QUORUM CENTER
GALGIANI ON THIS ITEM SORRY
SENATOR.
GLAZERS ASSISTANCE IS IN MY
DISTRICT ALSO I'M JUST WANTING
TO MAKE SURE THIS IS AT THE END
OF CORAL HOLLOW ROAD.
THIS AREA.
AND TRACY UGH WELL THE PART
ACTUALLY -- BEGINS ON TESLA ROAD
WHICH IS -- IN THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY THE PARK IS ENTIRELY
KNOWN A COUNTY IN ON THE
BEGINNING PART.
IS ON VIEW IF YOU SEE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PARK FROM
LIVERMORE YOU CAN ACTUALLY SEE
IT.
WITH RIGHT FROM CITY HALL I
THINK CARNEGIE IS NEAR CORRAL
CORAL CORAL HOLLOW ROAD I'M
TRYING TO PICTURE HOW TO GET
THERE FROM I TOOL FIVE AND YOU
WOULD I GUESS YOU WOULD EXIT
CALL HOLLOW.
DR AND HEAD SOUTH.
I THINK SO -- BECAUSE I HAVE
BEEN THERE AND I HAVE BEEN TO
CORRAL HOLLOW ROAD SO I THINK
THERE IS A LINK THERE -- BUT
THIS IS FAR THERE.
THE TESLA IS FARTHER WEST SIR OF
FEW MILES WEST.
AND ISN'T TO TO CARNEGIE TO BUT
IT'S AN ALAMEDA COUNTY CARNEGIE
IS PRIMARILY.
ALMOST A 9095% YOUNG NOW
STANISLAUS COUNTY.
OKAY THANK YOU CAN ACCESS IT
FROM ALL [inaudible]
HELLO THIS [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M SORRY SAN WORKING HERE.
I WAS ALMOST PRESSURED TO GOOGLE
THAT AND JUST FIND OUT FOR SURE --
ALAN.
OKAY SO THE LAND THAT IS IN THIS
AREA WHAT IS.
HAPPENING ON THAT LAND NOW.
IT'S UP TO THE CHAIR.
YEAH SO THERE'S AN EXISTING OFF
ROAD HIGHWAY PARK RIGHT NEXT
DOOR OKAY.
THIS IS A JASON LAND THAT'S BEEN
ACQUIRED.
ADJACENT LAND GOD HEADING
TOWARDS THE CITY OF LIVERMORE.
AND WHAT'S WHAT'S ON THE LAND
RIGHT OPEN SPACE IT WAS RATE IS
A HIKING TRAILS ARE NO I I
BELIEVE IT SAID IT FIRST SO I
DON'T THINK I'M AT A STOP YOU
RIGHT HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD.
HERE SIDE HERE WELL PRESIDENT
WELL CARE ALLEN PRESENT ALLEN
HERE ARCHULETA.
AGILITY HERE BARGES BRADFORD.
CHIANG CHING HERE GALGIANI
GALGIANI HERE GLAZER PLEASE ARE
HERE HILL.
HELLO HERE WEST SO.
JONES.
NELSON NELSON HERE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
RUBIO WIENER.
AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT I WAS A
VISIBLE WAY LOW YET -- NO WE'RE
GOING TO LET CENTER GLAZER
FINISH AND THEN WE'LL GO THROUGH --
AND VOTE ON SOME OF THESE.
THOUGH. FOR THE MOST PART IT'S
PADLOCKED AREA OR IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT EVEN IT'S NOT ALLOWABLE EVEN
PASSIVE OPEN SPACE LEGALLY.
IT'S IN THE POSSESSION OF STATE
PARKS THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
OFFICIAL PUBLIC ENTRY ON IT --
TODAY -- THAT I'M AWARE OF TO BE
THROUGH IT ALL YOU'RE SEEKING TO
DO IS.
GIVE THE STATE PARK THE RIGHT
THE STATE PARK SYSTEM THE RIGHT
TO DO.
WITH THAT AS A FEEL IS THE BEST
A LOOK INTERESTED IN ADVANCING A
PLAN TO EXPAND THE OFFER HIGHWAY
VEHICLE AREA IF THEY DECIDE THEY
DON'T WANT TO ADVANCE THOSE
PLANS ANY FURTHER.
THEN IT GIVES THEM AN OPTION TO
SELL IT AND GET ALL THE MONEY
BACK THAT'S ALL IT DOES.
THEY COULD THEY ALSO DECIDED
JUST MAKE IT A REGULAR STATE
PARK OR A OR IS THAT THEY COULD
DO -- WELL THIS BILL ONLY DEALS
WITH THE ISSUE OF SELLING IT AS
SURPLUS PROPERTY WHATEVER THE
CURRENT LAW OR CODE ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO -- IF THEY
CHOOSE TO HOLD ON TO IT IT WOULD
WOULD STILL BE IN PLACE IN WOULD
BE AFFECTED BY THIS BILL WHO ARE
THE RESTRICTIONS TO THE KIND OF
THE FOLKS THEY COULD SELL IT TO
A SURPLUS PROPERTY -- THERE
THERE'S THERE'S CODE THERE'S
LOTS A IN REGARD TO THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY THE BILL IS HERE
BECAUSE WHEN. SIXTEEN
LEGISLATORS ALL LAST THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT CONSIDER THE SALE
THEY SAID WE DON'T EVEN HAVE THE
LAWFUL RIGHT ONE OF MY QUESTIONS
I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF ROOM IN
THE FOLKS HERE IN SUPPORT.
MEAN ISN'T THERE A CONCERN THAT
IF IT WERE TO BE SOLD OFF --
AMANDA AND I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT THE RULES BUT THAT --
HERE'S THIS.
PORTION OF OPEN SPACE -- AND IT
COULD BE USED FOR DEVELOPMENT OR
OR OTHER -- USES THAT MAY BE OF
CONCERN.
GIVEN THE FACT IT'S ONE OF THE
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL AREA OF A SPACE
IN THE AND YOUR PORTION.
OF THE BAY AREA I DON'T KNOW OF
ANY OTHER PLANS THAT THEY HAVE
AT THE MOMENT SO I DON'T WANT TO
SPECULATE ON IT EXCEPT THAT
WHATEVER THE CURRENT LAW WOULD
PROVIDE IN THAT REGARD WOULD BE
CHANGED BY THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS
THAT IF THE CHOICE WOULD BE.
TO SELL IT FOR CONSERVATION%
PURPOSES THIS BILL WOULD GIVE
THEM THAT THAT RIGHT.
CENTER I I DO HAVE -- THE
DEPARTMENT THE YOUR FROM THE
BILL.
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES SHALL SELL THE LAND
ONLY TO A LOCAL AGENCY OR
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOR USE
AS A PARK OR OTHER OPEN SPACE
PURPOSES OKAY LAND SHOULD BE
SOLD FOR NO LESS THAN THE
ORIGINAL PURCHASE PRICE NO LESS.
THAN THE ORIGINAL PURCHASE PRICE
BASED ON THE ACTUAL PARCELS TO
BE INCLUDED THE SALE THAT THAT'S
BASED ON THE PASSAGE OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU ARE ALSO ASKING
ABOUT UNDER EXISTING LOT TODAY
IF THEY CHOSE NOT TO EVEN
WITHOUT THIS BILL WHAT RIGHTS TO
THEY HAPPENED I I CAN'T.
SPEAK TO THAT EXCEPT THIS
DOESN'T CHANGE IT OKAY THAT'S
VERY HELPFUL OUT SO SO BASICALLY
THEY THEY HAVE A PROCEDURE THAT.
DID YOU KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
INTERNALLY ABOUT THE WAY THEY
DISPOSE OF THEIR LAND OUR USUAL
AS THEIR LAND OR A YOU KNOW TURN
IT INTO A AS WE ARE A AND AND
THIS JUST THIS GIVES THEM MORE
FLEXIBILITY.
SIMPLY GETS IN THE OPTION IF
THEY DECIDE NOT TO GO FORWARD
WITH THEIR PLANS TO EXPAND THE
PARK.
GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SELL IT FOR OPEN SPACE FOR
PURPOSES AND IT WOULDN'T IMPACT
THE CURRENT.
RECREATIONAL USE.
THAT'S HAPPENING NOW AS I SAID
THE EXISTING OFF HIGHWAY PARK
ISN'T TO AFFECT IT AT ALL BY
THIS BILL.
AND THIS BILL DOES ENFORCE
ANYTHING JUST GIVE THEM AN
OPTION OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EVERY OTHER DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
THEIR MOTION -- BY SENATOR HILL.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR
JUST IN CLOSING THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE TO PASS
THIS LEGISLATION IN PREVIOUS
YEARS THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THE ONL CHANGES THE WAY ONE OF
THE WITNESSES INDICATED IS THAT.
THERE IS A CONCERN ABOUT THE
SALE PRICE OF WERE TO HAPPEN SO
THIS BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY TO CREATE A FLOOR.
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO GET ALL
THEIR MONEY BACK.
AT A MINIMUM AT A MINIMUM AND
THAT'S THE ONLY CHANGE FROM WHEN
YOU HAD LAST HEARD IT LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
GREG WE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
THIS IS A DO PASSED TO
OPERATIONS FILE ITEM THIRTEEN SB
SEVEN SIX SEVEN MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO CORPORATIONS COMMITTEE
DODD.
I THOUGHT I WILL KNOW WILK NO
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
AYE BARGES.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL HI WES SO [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO PORTANTINO.
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER. SEVEN SIXTY TWO THE
SIXTY TWO THIS BILLS ON CALL
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
CENTER MORE LOCK.
SB.
FIVE NINE EIGHT ITEM NUMBER.
NINE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORTS ARE PREPARED ANNUALLY BY
MUNICIPALITIES AND ARE BASED ON
THEIR AUDITED FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS.
THEY WANT THEY MUST ALSO BE
PRODUCED IN PDF FORMAT.
WHICH ALMOST ALL OF THEM DO.
OTHER SIMILAR REPORTS ARE ALSO
PREPARED.
THE PEOPLE GETTING EFFORTS AND
COULD RESULT IN TYPOGRAPHICAL
ERRORS.
I. X. B. R. L. WOULD REQUIRE
PREPARATION ONCE WITH THE
INFORMATION PROPAGATING OTHER
FORMS.
THUS SAVING CONSIDERABLE
PREPARATION TIME IN AVOIDING
YOURS.
ADOPTING AYE XBRL IS THE GOAL OF
SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT WHICH
STARTS THE RESEARCH PROCESS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION.
IN LINE EXTENSIBLE BUSINESS
REPORTING LANGUAGE IS AN OPEN
SOURCE FINANCIAL DATA STANDARD.
IT UTILIZES A DIGITAL DICTIONARY
OR TAXONOMY FOR CLASSIFICATIONS
IN TERMS.
PDF'S ARE DIFFICULT TO TRANSFER
INTO AN EXCEL SPREADSHEET.
IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE MAKING
COMPUTER READING OF FINANCIALS
LABOR INTENSIVE.
I XPERIA IS LIKE TAGGING THE
WEBSITE.
YOU CAN SEARCH TERMS INSTANTLY
YOU CAN ALSO COMPARE CAPPERS
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
PORTS IN SECONDS VERSUS HOURS.
THIS SUFFICIENT MONEY SAVING
TECHNOLOGY IS ALREADY IN USE
AROUND THE GLOBE.
IN THE U. S. THE SEC REQUIRES AT
SIX THOUSAND PUBLICLY TRADED
CORPORATIONS TO REPORT WITH IT.
THE FDIC DOES THE SAME FOR EIGHT
THOUSAND BANKS AUSTRALIA HAS
ALREADY SEEN MORE THAN ONE
BILLION IN COST SAVINGS WITH ITS
MUNICIPALITIES.
AND THEY HAVE TWENTY FOUR
MILLION RESIDENTS.
THERE ARE NO LICENSING FEES IT'S
NOT SOFTWARE IT'S A STANDARD IT
ADOPTS TO REPORTING ADAPTS USE
ME.
TOO REPORTING AND TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES IS [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
SENATOR GLAZER HAS ALSO
REQUESTED TO BE A CO AUTHOR IT
FIVE MAKE TAKE AMENDMENTS AND
HOPEFULLY I THINK THAT'S GOING
TO CHANGE THE VOTE RIGHT AWAY I
KEEP GOING.
DAHLE SCRATCHES NAY MOCK -- ARE
ALSO GETTING A GOOD FEEDBACK
FROM TREASURE FIANNA MáS OFFICE.
THIS IS WHY CONVERTING CAMERAS
THAT HAVE.
FILM TO DIGITAL WE ARE MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION IT'S THE
FUTURE AND WE NEED TO CATCH UP
ESPECIALLY AS A HIGH TECH STATE.
ONCE IT'S IMPLEMENTED OUR CITIES
BONDHOLDERS RATING AENCIES AND
TAXPAYERS WILL WONDER.
WHAT TOOK US SO LONG --
COLLEAGUES THIS IS AN EXCITING
OPPORTUNITY -- I AND I ENCOURAGE
AN AYE VOTE ON SB FIVE NINETY
EIGHT AND I HAVE A WITNESS
MISTER DIXON RIGHT.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK STRIDE
THANK YOU.
FIRST OFF THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK HERE TODAY ON SB.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT THE DECISION
TO FORM A COMMITTEE TO EXPLORE
THE XP ARE ALL STANDARDS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I MYSELF AM ACTIVE IN THE
FINANCIAL MARKETS AND I PROVIDE
INFO A CREDIT. TO VARIOUS
ENTITIES AND I RELY ON THEIR
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS AND WE
CURRENTLY USE THE XP ARE ALL FOR
ALL PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANIES.
OUR UNDERWRITERS CAN IMPORT THAT
INFORMATION AND SO IT'S ALREADY
AVAILABLE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AND IS ALREADY BEING USED.
I AM ALSO INVOLVED IN AN EFFORT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY TO
EXPAND THE TAXONOMY TO INCLUDE
THE DATA FIELDS NECESSARY FOR
BUILDING ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND RECENTLY EXPANDED THE
TAXONOMY BY OVER FIVE THOUSAND
DATA ELEMENTS. TO BRING IN THE
FINANCIAL MARKETS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FINANCING AND WHATNOT TO
MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
MANY OF WHICH WILL BE FUNDED BY
MUNICIPAL BONDS WERE BY GREEN
BOND FUNDS. THIRTY IS A
FINANCIAL GUARANTEE WE LIVE ON
THE INFORMATION WE RECEIVE THE
BETTER THE INFORMATION WE
RECEIVE A MORE ACCURATE IT IS
THE BETTER WE CAN DO OUR JOBS.
SO PROVIDING THE DIGITAL
INFORMATION AS A SENATORS
MENTIONED ALLOWS FOR THAT
CAPABILITY.
AND I STRONGLY SUGGEST THAT THAT
HAS GOING TO HAVE A MAJOR
FINANCIAL IMPACT TOWARDS
EFFICIENCY.
THE CASF REPORTING ALSO
GENERATES.
A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
CONSISTENT DATA ELEMENTS THAT
WOULD BE VERY VALUABLE TO THE
FINANCIAL MARKETS.
AND THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
THE NEW EMERGING FAN TEX
CONSTRUCTED SURE TECH AND ALL
THE VARIOUS NEW TECHNOLOGIES
THAT ARE BEING DEVELOPED.
THOSE NEW TOOLS AND RESOURCES
WILL HAVE ALSO SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT.
DATE INTERRUPT ABILITY TO THE
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND THE PRIVATE
INDUSTRY IS GOING TO BE A BIG
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT AS WELL.
AND WHILE THERE ARE MANY
DIFFERING VIEWS ON ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT PRIORITY POLICIES.
I WOULD SUGGEST TO YOU THAT
THERE IS A CONSISTENT VIEW THAT
EFFICIENCY IS IMPORTANT FOR OUR
STATE.
AND I RECOMMEND THAT YOU.
SUPPORT SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT AND
ALLOW THAT EFFICIENCY TO TAKE
HOLD IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHICH LEADS THE NATION.
THANK YOU MISTER RIGHT -- THEIR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI.
MY NAME IS JOHN LIEBERMAN UP
WITH THE STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE -- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL IN RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AB WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE TURN BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
SURREAL SIN WE HAVE A MOTION TO
APPROVE CAN WE CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE VIOLENTLY SECOND CENTER
MORE LIKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER --
THIS IS TECHNOLOGY THAT EVEN THE
BOND MARKET IS EXCITED TO SEE IS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MOVING A
BILL LIKE THIS SO THIS SICK KIND
OF CATCHES UP AND AND SET AN
EXAMPLE FOR THE REST OF THE
NATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
IN THE TREASURE SUPPORTING IT
YOU KNOW RUMORS CONFIRMED.
IT IS CONFRONT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
NINE SB FIVE NINE EIGHT MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD HI DODD HI WILL.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
AYE BARGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER. NINE THIS BILLS ON CALL.
THAT'S NINE VOTES THIS BILL WILL
BE PUT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR ALAN.
THIS ITEM NUMBER ONE SB.
THREE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
PERSON -- I'D LIKE TO INVITE MY
JOINT AUTHOR ON SB THREE A
CENTER GLAZER WHO.
CURRENTLY WAS VERY INFLUENTIAL
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF CENTER
MORE LOCKS BILL.
THESE IS A BIG DEAL SENATE
GLAZER.
A BIG BIG DEAL OKAY SO THIS BILL
SB -- THREE ESTABLISHES THE
OFFICE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
COORDINATION ACCOUNTABILITY
PERFORMANCE.
AND IS THE DRESS IS A GAP THAT
WE'VE HAD AS A POLICY MATTER FOR
SOMETIME -- AND THIS OFFICE WILL
ARTICULATE STATE GOALS CORNEIL
BETWEEN HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS.
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND ASSIST THE
STATE AND ESTABLISHING CLEAR
HIGHER EDUCATION AGENDA.
THAT SERVE STUDENTS AND MEETS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND WORK
FORCE DEMANDS.
THE FOLKS WHO FOLLOW THIS AREA
OF POLICY MAKING NOTE THAT --
BACK IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
AND IS ACTUALLY COMING OUT OF
THE MASTER PLAN THE CALIFORNIA
POSTSECONDARY.
EDUCATION COMMISSION C. PACK.
WAS ESTABLISHED IN IT WAS
ESTABLISHED TO SERVE AS A CORD
EATING AND PLANNING BODY FOR
HIGHER AT WE'VE GOT ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT BODIES.
IN HIGHER ED FROM THE
COMMUNICABLE EDGES TO THE YOU
SEE THE CAL STATE INDEPENDENCE
AND THEN THE PIPELINE FROM --
FROM K. THROUGH TWELVE AND WE
WANTED TO HAVE BETTER
COORDINATION.
AND IT SERVE THE STATE VERY WELL
BUT ULTIMATELY -- GOVERNOR BROWN
I THINK LOST FAITH.
IN THE IN THE COMMISSION AND IN
PARTICULAR IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
DOWNTURN ALL THE BUDGET CUTS
THAT WERE HAPPENING.
AT THE TIME.
HI HE ULTIMATELY GOVERNOR BROWN --
ZEROED OUT FUNDING FOR C. PACK --
OVER THE LEGISLATURE STRONG
OBJECTIONS.
NOW THE LA -- HAS I THINK THAT
WAS THE YOU'D BE RECOGNIZED
THERE WERE SOME PROBLEMS AND
CHALLENGES WITH THE C. PACK
STRUCTURE.
AND THE LA ALWAYS COME BACK AND
SAID LOOK THE LEGISLATURE REALLY
OUGHTA REESTABLISHING DEPEND
OVERSIGHT BODY FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION LEARN FROM THE
CHALLENGES THE PAST.
AND COME UP WITH A NEW
INDEPENDENT OFFICE THAT WILL
FOCUS ON QUALITY PROGRAM
OVERSIGHT REVIEW AND ANALYZE A
VARIETY OF DATA INCLUDING
GRADUATION RATES AFFORDABILITY.
FINANCIAL AID TO GREEN
CERTIFICATION COMPLETION --
TRANCE -- FOR TRANSFER ISSUES
WE'RE WORK FIRST COORDINATION
AND JUST A CORONATION IN GENERAL
BETWEEN ALL OF OUR DIFFERENT
INSTITUTIONS.
OF EDUCATION -- THE OFFICE AS
SOON SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO
CREATE THIS OFFICE AND IT WILL
BE A GREAT OFFICE THAT WILL HAVE
INDEPENDENT POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WILL BE
MADE TO THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR PROVIDE A VISION. TO
ENSURE ACADEMIC AND WORK FOR
SUCCESS -- FOR IS CURRENT AND
FUTURE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND
SO I I THINK IT WILL HELP TO TO
DO REFILL OUR GAP THAT EXISTS
EVER SINCE THE PACK.
WAS TAKEN AWAY -- SO OBVIOUSLY
WE HAVE CENTER GLAZER WHO I'M
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH AN SP --
TWO AND ON THIS BILL AS WELL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT AND THEN I
WILL INTRODUCE ARE ARE A
FANTASTIC -- WITNESSES.
JUST BRIEFLY MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU TO CENTER ALLEN MIGHT
I JOIN AUTHOR ON THIS BILL AND
SB TWO SB TWO IS A LONGITUDINAL
DATA BILL.
WE WANT THIS NEW AGENCY TO HAVE
FACTS AND RESEARCH TO MAKE GOOD
CHOICES AND GOOD JUDGMENT AND
GOOD INSIGHT TO SHARE WITH US.
WE NEED BOTH THINGS TOGETHER WE
NEED A RECREATION OF THIS
OVERSIGHT GROUP AND WE EED THAT
THE RESEARCH DONE SO THAT WE CAN
LEARN FROM AND MAKE GOOD CHOICES
AND THAT'S WHAT THESE TWO BILLS
ABOUT AND CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT SB THREE AND HOPE YOU
WILL.
TOO CENTER GLAZER WAS IT YOU THE
DEVELOP THE SIX LETTER ACRONYM
FOR THIS -- COMMISSION.
YES THERE WAS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT JUST SAYING --
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A REDUCING OF
THE BOT WHO'S REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA PIZZA AND ALSO THERE
ARE SAFE FROM THE CAMPAIGN
BECAUSE OPPORTUNITY.
AND YES IT ACTUALLY WASN'T A
GLAZER -- YOU KNOW DON'T LISTEN
TO HIM.
GOOD MORNING AT CHERRY DIED IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS RIA SEND UP TO FIVE I'M THE
INTERIM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA COMPETES HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR A STRONG ECONOMY.
WE ARE AN INDEPENDENT
NONPARTISAN NONPROFIT PROJECT
THAT HAS LONG SUPPORTED GREATER
OVERSIGHT AND COORDINATION IN
HIGHER EDUCATION TO PROMOTE
STUDENT SUCCESS.
I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL THREE THE STATE
FACES CRITICAL POSTSECONDARY
CHALLENGES INCLUDING RISING
COSTS CAPACITY CONSTRAINTS AN
INEQUITABLE OUTCOMES.
NO SEGMENT OR GOVERNING BODY IS
CHARGED WITH ADDRESSING THESE
CHALLENGES IN WHOLE.
NOW MORE THAN ANY OTHER TIME
SINCE THE MASTER PLAN FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION WAS CHARTERED THE
STATE NEEDS EXPERT LEADERSHIP TO
SUPPORT EQUITABLE COLLEGE ACCESS
AND COMPLETION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
WHILE THE SEGMENTS HAVE MADE
IMPORTANT EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
CHALLENGES AND HIGHER EDUCATION
SUCH AS AFFORDABILITY.
ACCESS TIME TO DEGREE
FUNDAMENTALLY THESE ARE
STATEWIDE PROBLEMS THAT
TRANSCEND ANY ONE INSTITUTION OR
SEGMENT AND THEY REQUIRE
SYSTEMIC SOLUTIONS.
THE OFFICE ESTABLISHED BY SB
THREE COULD TAKE A STATE WIE
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING ISSUES
SUCH AS INSTITUTIONAL CAPACITY
AND SUPPORTING CROSS SECTOR
INITIATIVES SUCH AS DUAL
ENROLLMENT IN TRANSFER PROGRAMS.
SPECIFICALLY SB THREE CREATED
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DEVELOP
STATEWIDE HIGHER EDUCATION GOALS
TO OVERSEE INTER AGENCY EFFORTS
AND TO PROMOTE EVIDENCE BASED
POLICY MAKING BY USING DATA.
ACROSS EDUCATION AND WORK FOR
CENTER IS FURTHER SB THREE
CAREFULLY THINGS THROUGH THE
APPROPRIATE ROLES OF KEY STAKE
HOLDERS CREATING ADVISORY BOARD
WITH STUDENT AND SEGMENT
REPRESENTATIVES.
THESE FUNCTIONS WILL IMPROVE
OUTCOMES ACROSS DIVERSE REGIONS
AND DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATIONS
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM REQUIRES COORDINATED
LEADERSHIP AND DATA DRIVEN
DECISION MAKING.
THAT CENTERS ON THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS AND FOR THESE REASONS
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES THERE
ARE SEE DIRECTOR OF POLICY NOW
ADVOCACY WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY.
A STATEWIDE POLICY AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND AND SUCCEED IN COLLEGE.
I'D LIKE TO THINK SENATORS ALLEN
IN GLACIER FOR THE LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB.
THREE WE KNOW THAT IN THE COMING
YEARS THE STATE WILL NEED A
GROWING SUPPLY OF EDUCATED
WORKERS TO MEET THE DEMANDS OF
AYE DYNAMICS -- STATE ECONOMY
AND THAT KEY TO FOR FILLING THIS
NEED WILL BE ENSURING THE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS OF THOSE POPULATIONS
THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN
UNDER REPRESENTED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
YET CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY STANDS
AS ONLY ONE OF TWO STATES
WITHOUT A STATEWIDE COORDINATING
BODY FOR HIGHER EDUCATION.
MEANING WE LACKED THE STATE
LEVEL LEADERSHIP RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE PLANNING OVERSIGHT AND
COORDINATION THAT POSITIONS THE
STATE TO MEET THESE CALLENGES.
A BODY THAT IS NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF ANY ONE SECTOR
SEGMENT BUT RATHER UNDERSTANDS
THE BROADER NEEDS OF THE STATE
AND CAN FACILITATE THE NECESSARY
CONVERSATIONS.
ANALYSIS AND EXPERTISE TOWARDS
THESE GOALS.
SB THREE RECOGNIZES THIS
CRITICAL VOID AND ESTABLISH A
STATE LEADERSHIP POSITION TO
CONFRONT THESE CHALLENGES AND
FOR THOSE REASONS.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I WILL.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION OH
SORRY -- HIS ABOUT SORT IN SEAT
BEHIND.
A HANNAH RAKKESTAD WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SEE NONE TURN BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
CENTER NIELSEN.
IF I MAY ASK A CENTER ALLEN THE
MASTER PLAN OF HIGHER ED WAS.
MENTIONED.
AND IT WAS FIRST PASSED IN THE
SIXTIES AND THROUGH THE EIGHTIES
WE REVIEWED THE MASTER PLAN.
THAT WAS A THREE YEAR EFFORT BY
A BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION AND A
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE -- I
WORKED WITH SENATOR VASCONCELOS.
AND THE MISSION GOALS IN IN
RELATIONSHIPS OF THE THREE
LEVELS OF HIGHER EDUCATION WERE.
I GUESS I WOULD SAY CONTEMPORARY
RISE DOOR MADE MORE CLEAR BY
VIRTUE OF THAT REVIEW.
NOW AND CREATING THIS ENTITY.
WILL THIS IN ANY LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL REQUIRE THEM TO BE GUIDED
BY THE MASTER PLAN IN PLACE SO
THAT THEY CAN'T JUST GO REINVENT
THE MASTER PLAN ON THEIR OWN.
THAT THAT SHOULD BE THE PURVIEW
OF THE LEGISLATURE SOLELY.
THERE ARE I WOULD CONSIDER AS
YOU MOVE ALONG SOME LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD MAKE IT EXPRESS
[inaudible]
THAT.
TO GUIDED BY THE MASTER PLAN ARE.
NO WITH THERE'S NO ON SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN
YEAH IN THE BILL BUT I I
CERTAINLY WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK
IN THE OFFICE THAT THAT'S NOT
IT'S NOT THE IT'S IT'S ACTUALLY
THE INTENT OF THE BILL. TO FIVE
TO TO FILL THE THE PROMISE THE
MASTER PLAN I MEAN AND AND I I
THE REASON WHY MATCH THE MASTER
PLAN IT'S ACTUALLY MENTIONED.
IN YOUR ANALYSIS ON PAGE FIVE IT
TALKS ABOUT HOW -- HOW THE
MASTER PLAN CREATED SEE BACK AS
AN OVERSIGHT BODY AND HOW IT SAW
THE THE NEED FOR COORDINATION
AND AND AND COOPERATION BETWEEN
THE BODIES?
SO I SEE IT AS AS ACTUALLY
AFFECTION IN THE MASTER PLAN --
BUT IF THERE'S A WAY TO ADD TO
PUT IN SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THAT
WILL.
YOU KNOW THAT WILL ADDRESS YOUR
CONCERN I BE HAPPY IF I MIGHT BE
MOVE THE BILL CENTER BUT I MIGHT
ASK TO WORK WITH SOME OF YOUR
STAFF JUST TO SEE IF WE COULD
SOME.
CLARITY LANGUAGE -- TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT MASTER PLAN REMAINS
THE ANCHOR.
I I'M NOT FEARFUL OF IT BUT
SOMETHING'S HAPPENED AROUND HERE
WHEN WE I UNDERSTAND THAT AND I
I MIGHT WE MIGHT SO I WILL BE
VERY HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY.
WHERE WE HAVE A MOTION -- ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD.
HI DODD AYE WILK HI WILK AYE
ALLEN AYE AYE ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I BARGES.
BARGES AYE BRADFORD.
CHANG.
CHANG AYE GALGIANI.
GLAZER GLAZER AYE HILL HILL AYE
WEST SO [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER.
THAT'S NINE THE BILL THE BILL
HAS NINE IT'S ON CALL -- I AM
GOING TO PRESENTS ALL PASSED THE
GAVEL NOT CENTER WILK
.
GOOD -- WITH CONTROL ISSUES.
GOOD MORNING STILL MISTER --
NEAR MEMBERS SB FOUR SIXTY NINE
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION WHEN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
OF HORSES OR JOCKEYS ARE AT RISK.
AS RECENT EVENTS HAVE SHOWN
EXISTING LAW LIMITS THE ABILITY
OF THE BOARD TO ACT QUICKLY.
IN PROVIDES LIMITED IN COVER
SOME OPTIONS TO ADDRESS SAFETY
CONCERNS.
MEMBER MUCH THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
THE BOARD TO TEMPER LAWYERS
TEMPORARILY SUSPEND A HORSE
RACING LICENSE IN EXTREME
CONDITIONS AFTER AFFECTING
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
IN EXCEPT THE BOARD FROM THE
CURRENT TEN DAY MEETING
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS IN THE
BAT BRADLEY KEEN.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL CLARIFIES
THE BOARDS EXISTING AUTHORITY TO
CHANGE OR REALITY RACING DAYS.
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY ALLOCATED.
HORSE RACING IN CALIFORNIA IS A
RICH AND STORIED HISTORY.
TODAY THE INDUSTRY PROVIDES
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY ITS WARTS
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HOWEVER THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
HORSES AND JOCKEYS MUST BE A
PRIORITY.
NOW IS THE TIME TO MAKE
THOUGHTFUL CHANGES THAT WILL
HELP TO ENSURE THE HORSES AND
JOCKEYS ARE PROTECTED.
IN THE INDUSTRY CAN CONTINUE TO
OPERATE SUCCESSFULLY CALIFORNIA.
FOR YEARS TO COME.
I THINK WE WOULD ALL AGREE THAT
ONE HORSE RACING DEATH IS TOO
MANY AND APPLY THE INDUSTRY AND
THE BOARD FOR WORKING OVER THE
LAST DECADE. TO LOWER HORSE Và
TH<c.cyan> IX.</c>
THISBILL IS INTENDED TO
CONTINUE THAT TREND IT PROVIDE
THE BOARD WITH THE TOOL TO ACT.
WHEN IT'S ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY?
THIS BILL IS GOOD FOR THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY RACE HORSES AND
JOCKEYS AND IS GOOD FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE INDUSTRY THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY TO ANSWER TECH TO
QUESTIONS RED BATIC UBER BAKER
FOR ME THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD.
IN ROBERT BROAD NICK THE STAFF
COUNSEL AT THE HORSE CALIFORNIA
HORSE RACING BOARD [inaudible]
GREAT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
JUSTIN FANS ALL ON BEHALF THE
SKEW THE THOROUGHBRED OWNERS
CALIFORNIA AND DEL MAR
THOROUGHBRED CLUB LET'S DO THINK
THE AUTHOR.
FOR WORKING WITH US OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS ON THIS
ISSUE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM IN THE FUTURES --
AS A BILLABLE FORWARD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE GOOD AFTERNOON
JUDY MAN CREW SO PRESIDENT
FOUNDER SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION IT IS TIME TO RAISE
THE STANDARDS AND WE THANK
SENATOR DODD SO MUCH. FOR TAKING
A STEP FORWARD WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU YOU.
GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME IS
DOCTOR HAD THE RALLY AND THE
SUPERVISING VETERINARIAN AT THE
PITA FOUNDATION AND ON BEHALF OF
PETER'S SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS INCLUDING
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND OF WHOM
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
COULD WELL TO BE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA THIRTY RACING FAIRS
AND WE LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND STAFF FOR CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH US WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION YET.
WILL PROBABLY TAKEN ONE NEXT
WEEK BUT WE APPRECIATE THE
DIALOGUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER
SCOTT WHAT YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STROKE GROUP THE OWNERS HAVE.
ALL SANTA ANITA RACE WAY AND
GOLDEN GATE FIELDS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
COLLABORATION WITH THE CHAIR ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU.
ANY -- THOSE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THREE NINE A PULL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS -- WE HAVE A MOTION TO
GO HEADS CENTER NIELSEN.
AS YOU PROCEED.
THERE'S SOME CONCERN I HAVE WITH
THE THE THE CHAIR HAVING A
LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH AUTHORITY IT
IT SPEAKS HERE TO THE ABILITY TO
CALL OF AN EMERGENCY MEETING
WITH AS LITTLE AS AN HOUR NOTICE
AND THEN TAKING A UNILATERAL
ACTION -- THE THIS COULD BE A
RATHER SIGNIFICANT TO THE EVENT
SO.
THANK YOU MAY NEED TO BE SOME
WORK AND BALANCING THAT LANGUAGE
OUT A LITTLE BIT.
IT WAS SPEAKER DOWN THERE YES
SORRY IT TOOK ME LONGER TO GET
UP THE ELEVATORS AND I HAD
PLANNED -- MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROBIN BLACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA THOROUGHBRED BREEDERS
ASSOCIATION WE WANNA PLOT THE
AUTHOR FOR ALL HIS HARD WORK ON
THIS ISSUE.
AND WE APPRECIATE IT GREATLY.
MY PHILOSOPHY IS A HORSE OWNER
AND REPRESENTED WITH THE
THOROUGHBREDS HAS PUT THE HORSE
FIRST IN THE SPORTS SECOND.
SO I THINK YOU FOR THE GREAT
WORK YOU'RE DOING IN.
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH WE ARE
IN SUPPORT.
A GREAT THANK YOU THE SHARE TO
CENTER NIELSEN -- IT'S IT'S NOT
THE CHAIRMAN IT'S THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR BUT I THINK YOUR
THOUGHTS WOULD STILL BE THE SAME
ON THAT ISSUE MORE HAPPY -- TO
WORK ON THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
THAT COMMENT.
SEE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS WE HAD A MOTION FROM
THE CENTER HILL THE
RECOMMENDATION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATE -- I'M SORRY SENATOR
RUBIO AND KILL.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I'M ALSO PROUD
TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL --
ESPECIALLY SINCE TEN ANY DOT --
RACE TRACK IS IN MY DISTRICT.
AND AND I'M REALLY A FIRST HAS
REALLY CONCERNED DODD PEOPLE
OUTSIDE THE BUILDING -- WERE
RUSHING -- TO TRY TO SHUT IT
DOWN AND MAKING COMMENTS THAT I
THINK IN THIS CASE THERE'S A LOT
OF JOBS AT STAKE A LOT OF FUN
MEMBERS OF MY COMMUNITY COMING
TO ME WITH CONCERNS.
ABOUT THEIR LIVELIHOOD AND SO AS
WE MOVE FORWARD I APPRECIATED ON
MICHAEL AUTHORS AND TAKING THE
TIME TO REALLY THAT THE
INFORMATION FIND OUT.
WHAT THE PROBLEM IS AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE MOVE CAUTIOUSLY SO
AS TO NOT AFFECT THE LIVES OF
ALL THESE PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU?
CENTER THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION CENTER
HILL THE RECOMMENDATION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK FILE ITEM SIX SB FOUR SIX
NINE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS DOT.
HI DODD I WILL TRY WILK AYE
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I BARGES.
BARGES I BRADFORD.
CHANGE HI CHIANG AYE GALGIANI
[inaudible]
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL HI WES SO.
JONES HI.
JONES HI NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
HI.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
ATTENDED ZERO THE BILLS ON TEN
ZERO SO THE BILLS OUT THE WE'LL
LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR MEMBERS TO
ADD ON TO THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM
THREE SB.
THREE FIFTY TWO I BELIEVE THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
AARON MEMBERS SB THREE RIGHT
THREE FIVE TWO WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF A..
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
COMMISSION TO ISSUE UP. TO TEN
NEW TYPE FORTY SEVEN LICENSES IN
THOSE COUNTIES THAT HAVE REACHED
THE CURRENT LIMIT OF ALCOHOL
LICENSES.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW CURRENT LAW
PLACES A LIMIT ON THE NUMBER OF
ON SALE GENERAL LICENSES. TO
WHAT LICENSE FOR EVERY TWO
THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN THAT
COUNTY.
WELL THIS SYSTEM CERTAINLY WORKS
FOR MOST THERE ARE A LARGE
NUMBER OF COUNTIES WHERE THE
DEMAND -- FOR LICENSES FAR
OUTWEIGHS THE CURRENT NUMBER.
HE NAPA COUNTY FOR INSTANCE THE
POPULATION IS LOW THAT'S THE
NUMBER OF LICENSED IS AS WELL
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF TOURISM IN
THE DEMAND FOR RESTAURANTS.
WHO SERVE ALCOHOL IS MUCH HIGHER --
THIS IS IMPORTANT HE INDIVIDUALS
HOPING TO OPEN A RESTAURANT IN
THOSE COUNTIES ARE FORCED TO GO
TO THE OPEN MARKET.
WE'RE LICENSES CAN COST UPWARDS
OF FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN OBSTACLE THAT MANY CANNOT
OVERCOME.
THIS RESULT IN THE LOSS OF
REVENUES TO OUR CITIES IN OUR
STATE NOT TO MENTION A LOTS OF
JOBS FOR COMMUNITIES.
AS EMAIL SUSPENSIONS THE THIS
BILL ONLY APPLIES TO TYPE FORTY
SEVEN LICENSES WHICH ARE MORE
COMMONLY USED TO OPEN
RESTAURANTS.
LICENSES FROM BEING SOLD FOR
MORE THAN THEY ARE PURCHASED --
PURCHASED WHICH SHOULD DIMINISH --
THE IMPACT ON CURRENT LICENSES
MEMBERS AT A TIME MORE DEMAND
FOR RESTAURANTS IS AN ALL TIME
HIGH IT IS TIME FOR US TO RE
EVALUATE HOW THE STATE ISSUES
THESE LICENSES.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS A STEP
FORWARD IN THAT DIRECTION I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS PAT CHOICE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS PAT
CHOICE I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATIONS REPRESENTING
APPROXIMATELY -- TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED EATING ESTABLISHMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I'M PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB THREE
FIFTY TWO A WELL BOUNCE MEASURE
THAT WOULD PERMIT NO MORE THAN
TEN OR TEN NEW ORIGINAL ON STILL
GENERAL LICENSES PER YEAR FOR
RESTAURANTS AND COUNTIES THAT
HAVE REACHED.
THE LIMIT ON ON SALE JOURNAL
LICENSES -- WHY THE NEED FOR THE
BILL?
THE DEMAND FOR ON SALE OUT THE
WHOLE LICENSES HAS EXCEEDED THE
CAP ON SUCH LICENSES MANY
POPULAR TOURIST DESTINATIONS
SUCH AS SAN FRANCISCO NAPA A LOS
ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY IN SAN
DIEGO.
RESULTED IN EXPENSIVE ONLINE --
ON SALE LICE'S CREATE A BARRIER
OF ENTRY. FOR SOMEONE TRYING TO
OPEN A NEW RESTAURANT.
THE BARRIER TO ENTRY SLOWS DOWN
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND JOB CREATION
LOCAL ECONOMIES.
SB THREE FIFTY TWO ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE BY ALLOWING FOR A
LIMITED NUMBER OF NEW ORIGINAL
ON SALE LICENSES PER YEAR FOR
BONAFIDE EATING PLACES ONLY.
SO THEY CAN ONLY BE USED TO OPEN
UP.
A NEW RESTAURANTS.
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WILL BENEFIT
FROM THE RESTAURANT ELEMENT.
THE EMPLOYEES THAT COME WITH
THAT INVESTMENT AND THE
ASSOCIATED SALES TAX DOLLARS
THAT WILL BE GENERATED FROM
THESE LOCATIONS LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE.
WHICH WILL STIMULATE LOCAL
ECONOMIC GROWTH LIMIT THE NUMBER
OF NEW LICENSES WITHIN A GIVEN
COUNTY.
AND HELP FOSTER SYSTEM OF OF
INCENTIVES THAT ACTUALLY.
USE THESE LICENSES FOR THESE
REASONS AND OTHER REASONS WE ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU GOT ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. THREE NINE IN IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING THEM PULL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR GORGEOUS.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN --TURNED OUT
CAN YOU EXPLAIN A BIT FURTHER ON
THE DYNAMIC OF A THESE LICENSES --
ESCALATE IN PRICE AND CREATE
THIS KIND OF BIZARRE MARKET FOR
FOR THEM HE'S GOING TO GO ON A
BIT MORE ABOUT THAT.
YEAH SURE A BABY IS CLEARLY JUST
A SUPPLY AND DEMAND ISSUE --
PEOPLE NEED ALCOHOL LICENSES IF
THEY'RE GOING TO OPERATE A
RESTAURANT PARTICULARLY IN THE
HEAVILY TOURIST AREA OR
YELLOWING IN JUST IN THE
CULINARY.
HIGHER QUALITY OR ACTUALLY ANY
CULINARY EVEN AT SO YOU HAVE
VERY FEW LICENSES HIGH DEMAND
THE PRICES PRICE JUST GOES UP
AND IT IS GONE UP AND UP AND UP.
YOU OVER THE YEARS -- MA'AM
WE'VE TRIED TO BAD DATE
APPROACHES ONE OF THEM WOULD BE
A TYPE SEVENTY FIVE LICENSE
PEOPLE BREWING BEER BUT WE FOUND
OUT CENTER BRADFORD HAD A BILL
LAST YEAR.
WE FOUND OUT THAT -- YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WERE JUST.
YEAH BREWING BEER TO GET THE
ALCOHOL LICENSE AND IT JUST IT
REALLY WASN'T WORKING AND WE
WERE HAVING.
IF FOR SOME ISSUES THERE AND SO
THIS SEEM TO BE THE BEST STEP
FORWARD. ONE DEFINITELY
SUPPORTIVE I THINK ANYTHING THAT
WE CAN DO TO HELP OUT THE THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY
WHEN THERE'S A FOOD COMPONENT --
IN PRINCIPALLY THESE ARE
RESTAURANTS THAT ARE SERVING
ALCOHOL NOT BARS -- ABSOLUTELY
HELPED INDUSTRIES OUT.
VITAL COMPONENT OF OUR ECONOMY.
THANK YOU SIR BORDER SENATOR
JONES.
THANK YOU SHARE MISTER DOT I
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THE BILL AS
WELL AND AS FACT -- YOU KNOW
ANYWHERE TO GO A STEP FORWARD
FARTHER.
RIGHT CAN'T MAYBE WE CAN DO
LATER THIS YEAR I DON'T KNOW IT
JUST REMOVE THE CAP IN IT IT'S
IT STIFLES INNOVATION IT -- IT
SERVES AS A ROADBLOCK FOR NEW
PEOPLE TO GET INTO THE INDUSTRY.
AND I DON'T GET GET THIS
LICENSING SCHEME SO I WAS
SUPPORT I SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND
WHAT SUPPORT EVEN GOING A STEP
FURTHER.
CAME BILLS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
GLAZER ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE.
YEAH I GUESS MISTER KERRY UP
PLAY ON A CLOSE [inaudible]
WELL.
WHAT I ASK FOR AYE VOTE?
FILE ITEM THREE SB THREE FIVE
TWO MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD.
AYE DODD AYE WILK HI WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE BARGES.
BARGES I BRADFORD.
CHIANG HI CHANGE I GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
HILL HILL AYE HUESO.
JONES.
JONES I NIELSEN AYE AYE NIELSEN
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
SAYS ELEVEN ZERO FOUR OKAY BUT
SO LEVIN ZERO SO THE BILLS OUT
BUT LEAVING ON CALL FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND I
RELUCTANTLY RETURNED.
THE GAVEL TO YOU.
OKAY SO WE NEED TO SENATOR STERN
FOR COPYING.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SENATOR STERN --
CABALLERO TO PRESENT THEIR BILLS
WITH THAT WILL MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CAN YOU CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
WE NEED A MOTION FIRST PLEASE
NOBODY CENTER ARCHULETA.
NOBODY WANTS TAKE ANYTHING OFF
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SEE AND
NONE WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE GOD -- I
THOUGHT I'D WILL HI WILK AYE
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
GORGEOUS. FOR JUST AYE BRADFORD.
CHANG CHANG AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO JONES HI JONES I
NIELSEN AYE AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER. ELEVEN TWO
ZERO THAT HAS ELEVEN VOTES IN
ITS -- ON ALL -- I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS GO BACK
THROUGH THE ROLE -- I KNOW THAT
SENATOR -- STERN IS CHAIRING
COMMITTEE AND THE VICE CHAIR IS
MISTER JONES.
SO -- WILL BUT WILL GO TO THE
THE THE ROLE ONCE ON ON THE
BILL'S.
FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE MOTION AS
YOU PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD
[inaudible]
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI I'D WEST SO.
JONES.
JONES I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
THAT'S TWELVE ZERO IT'S STILL
ZERO IT'S STILL ON CALL.
EARLY CENTER STERN FOUND
SOMEBODY ELSE -- TO CHAIR IS --
COMMITTEE WILL IN HIS ABSENCE
PLEASE PROCEED SENATOR.
YEAH YOU HAVE TO BILLS -- ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
WHATEVER ORDER LET'S START WITH
THE PUTS A LEVIN SB SEVEN THIRTY
OKAY.
HEY MISTER -- MR MEMBERS.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
WORK IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT [inaudible]
ROBOTICS AUTOMATION THREATS TO
THE WORK FORCE CHANGES IN THE
WORKPLACE -- BUT AT THIS POINT
B. ANALYSIS DRIVE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA STRATEGY IS
BORROWED NATIONAL IN SCOPE LACKS
REGIONAL GRANULARITY WE TRULY
DON'T KNOW.
WHAT THE RISKS REALLY ARE -- WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE -- AND AT THIS
POINT IS A LOT OF CONJECTURE
DRIVING BOTH OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
AGENDA -- WHEN IT COMES TO
AUTOMATION AS WELL AS OUR OUR
FUTURE PLANNING FOR THIS EONOMY
THIS BILL IS HOPEFULLY DESIGNED
TO GET AHEAD OF THAT THE
GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED HIS FUTURE
WORK COMMISSION -- IN HIS STATE
OF THE STATE AND THIS BILL WOULD
PUT.
A LEGISLATIVE BATCHES
CODIFICATION BUT LEGISLATIVE
VOICE INTO THAT COMMISSION TO
MAKE SURE NOT ONLY THAT WERE
INFORMED BY THE ANALYSES BUT
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY DRIVE THE
PROCESS -- AS WELL I IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GOVERNOR --
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS I MEAN WE ARE WE KNOW
SOME OF THE STATISTICS 50% I
THINK OF THE WORK FORCE
MACKENZIE ESTIMATES IS
SUSCEPTIBLE THE AUTOMATION OVER.
THE NEXT PERIOD OF TIME -- 5% OF
OCCUPATIONS COULD BE FULLY
AUTOMATED BY EXISTING
TECHNOLOGIES ACCORDING TO
MACKENZIE BUT AGAIN WE DO NOT
WANT FEAR OR DOUBT TO DRY THIS
AUTOMATION CONVERSATION WE WANT
NUMBERS AND DATA TO DRIVE THIS
STATE AND SO THAT'S THE PURPOSE
BEHIND THIS BILL WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
AND LOOK FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
OKAY I'M SORRY I'M HERE WITH
MATT HORTON ON BEHALF OF THE
MILKEN NSTITUTE IT WAS DID BEEN
DOING A LOT OF VERY IMPORTANT
HOUSES SOME IT'S CENTER.
ALL UP THANK YOU CENTERS ARE
MEMBERS.
SHARE COME UP AS CENTER SAID ON
MATT HORTON I AM REPRESENTING
THE MILKEN INSTITUTE CENTER FOR
REGIONAL ECONOMICS.
THE MILKEN INSTITUTE IS A
NONPROFIT NONPARTISAN ECONOMIC
POLICY THINK TANK.
AND IN OUR WORK IN IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT THE FUTURE OF WORK --
IN PREPARING CALIFORNIA FOR THE
FUTURE WORK WE BELIEVE IT IS
CRUCIAL THAT WE LEVERAGE
EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS INCREASE
NEW LINKS BETWEEN INDUSTRY AND
EDUCATION LEADERS.
THESE CONNECTIONS SHOULD BE THE
FOCUS ON CULTIVATING A PIPELINE
THAT SUPPORTS NIBBLE UPSCALING
PROGRAMS FOR WORKERS AT
DIFFERENT STAGES OF THEIR
CAREERS AND FOR VARIOUS INDUSTRY
NEEDS.
A COMMON THEME RESIN FOR MORE
WORK HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
WORKERS TO BE QUIPPED WITH THE
SKILLS THAT ARE COMPLEMENTARY TO
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS COMPUTER
LITERACY -- AS WELL AS
TRADITIONAL SKILLS AND
COMMUNICATION A MANAGEMENT THAT
CANNOT BE OFFSET BY AUTOMATION --
AS SENATOR STATED AND AND AN
OVERVIEW AUTOMATION SECTOR THE
UPSET OR DISRUPT AROUND 50% OF
THE U. S. JOBS BY -- TWENTY
FORTY IT IS ALSO EXPECTED -- TO
CREATE THE NEED FOR MORE
EMPLOYEES TO CONTINUOUSLY LEARN
OVER THE COURSE OF THEIR CAREERS --
AS TECHNOLOGY ACCELERATES THE
SPEED AT WHICH INDUSTRIES CHANGE --
FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE THINK --
IN ORDER TO MEET THIS CHALLENGE
WILL BE ESSENTIAL TO BRING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER TO DISCUSS
AREAS OF CONCERN OPPORTUNITIES
FOR COLLABORATION -- A STATE
COMMISSION COULD BE THE FIRST
STEP IN ENSURING CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AND WORKERS ARE
PREPARE FOR THIS NEXT ITERATION
OF JOBS -- IN PREPARING
CALIFORNIA FOR THE FUTURE OF
WORK WE CAN RE AFFIRM THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR NEW
GENERATION.
PROVIDING BY FOR ANY GREATER
ACCESS -- TO EQUITABLE SKILLS --
AND TECHNOLOGY IN SOFT SKILLS
THAT ARE ALSO NECESSARY
THROUGHOUT INVOLVING QUIRK
LANDSCAPE SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESSES SUPPORT.
DROUGHT COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THE BILL
IF AMENDED.
WE KNOW THE DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES
WILL BE IMPACTED DIFFERENTLY --
DUE TO CHANGES IN -- THE
WORKPLACE DUE TO AUTOMATION
TECHNOLOGY SO WE'RE SEEKING IS
INSTEAD OF ONE PRIVATE SECTOR
REPRESENTATIVES TO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DIFFERENT SECTORS ARE MOST
LIKELY TO BE IMPACTED.
CAMERA DIMITRI WITH TECHNO AND
NOW WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS
MATTHEW ALL OF WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE ALSO HAVE A
SUPPORT OF HIM IN A POSITION ON
THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING LOWER CURTIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF HIM IN A POSITION ON
THE BILL THANK SO MUCH.
IT WILL BE -- ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE TURN BACK -- TO THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
CENTER HELP.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANTED TO TO COMPLEMENT THE
AUTHORED THIS BILL WAS HEARD
LAST WEEK IN LABOR COMMITTEE AND
IT RECEIVED TREMENDOUS SUPPORT.
IT'S TIMELY AND NECESSARY TO GO
FORWARD WITH THAT SO
[inaudible]
CENTER GLAZER.
AT JUST A HISTORICAL NOTE -- IF
THAT RELATES TO THIS BILL IT
JUST IT TWO YEARS AGO -- THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED OUT A TRAILER
BILL THAT AS A CONDITION OF
FUNDING IN THIS CASE IT WAS THE
PORTS.
ARE PUT A PROHIBITION ON ON NOT.
THE THE WHAT WAS THE AUTOMATE
YOU COULDN'T USE THE MONEY. TO
USE AT IT COULD BE INVOLVED IN
ANY AUTOMATION ABOUT THAT WE
GAVE MONEY BUT SAID YOU COULD
USE IT FOR AUTOMATION.
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF FEAR IN
THIS SPACE AND APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WORK TO TRY TO GET IN
FRONT OF THIS SO WE CAN MAKE
GOOD CHOICES DOWN THE LINE
[inaudible]
CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU I THINK I SUPPORT YOUR
BILL THAT SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD
IDEA I'M I'M I'M.
ALWAYS HESITANT -- TO DEVELOP A
NEW COMMISSION -- THAT'S JUST
KIND OF MY NATURAL BEND BUT I
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT WORK I
DO HAVE ONE CONCERN.
LOOKING AT MY NOTES THAT -- THE
COMMISSION OF EIGHT MEMBERS
MANDATES THAT ONLY ONE MEMBER.
BE FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR IS
THAT ACCURATE.
IT IS THE ONLY REAL GRANULARITY
WE HAVE IN THE BILL IN TERMS OF
WHO REPRESENTS WHO IS ONE MEMBER
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND ONE
MEMBER FROM LABOR.
THERE'S REALLY NOT A LOT OF
CAN'T SORT OF GRANULARITY IN THE
MEASURE RIGHT NOW I'M VERY OPEN --
TO IDEAS ON EITHER EXPANDING TO
MULTIPLESECTORS AND GETTING
REALLY SPECIFIC -- AND INTENSELY
EVEN EXPANDING THE SCOPE OF THE
BOARD ALTHOUGH YOU GET INTO A A
PLACE FOR YOU KNOW DECISION
MAKING GETS COMPLICATED
DEPENDING ON HOW BIG IT GETS.
BUT IT'S IT'S GONNA BE HARD FOR
ONE PRIVATE SECTOR MEMBER OR
WHAT ONE SECTOR OF THE LABOR
ECONOMY FRANKLY A TEAMSTERS
GONNA HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
INTERESTS THAN SAY A NURSE OR A
OR A LONGSHOREMANRIGHT SO.
I THINK WE ARE GONNA HAVE TO TRY
TO FIND SOME WAY TO MAKE THIS
WORK THAT WE CAN COVER THOSE
MULTIPLE SECTORS AYE AYE IT'S A
VALID CONCERN.
AND I'M I'M OPEN TO IDEAS OKAY
SO YOUR VISION IS TO HAVE MORE
THAN ONE PERSON FROM THE PRIVATE
SECTOR BUT YOU'RE INCLUDING IN
THE BILL THAT.
AT LEAST ONE PURCHASE AGAIN AND
I YOU KNOW YOU FOR YOUR TIME
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF WORK YOU
KNOW.
MOST EMPLOYEES STILL IN
CALIFORNIA WORK FOR IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND THAT'S A
LARGE MARGIN I WOULD.
JUST ENCOURAGES IT MOVES DOWN
THE ROAD TO MAYBE.
EXPAND THAT MANDATE IN THE BILL
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO THERE CHIANG.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I WANT
TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
BILL -- IT THERE SEEMS TO BE A
LOT OF FEAR REGARDING AUTOMATION
AND I'VE BEEN.
TELLING A LOT OF FOLKS I JUST
DIDN'T POP CHALLENGE WITH KIDS
AND I SAID YOU HAVE TO GET IN
FRONT OF THIS.
BE THE CREATORS OF THE
TECHNOLOGY NOT JUST THE
CONSUMERS I THINK WE NEED TO
ALSO ADDRESS THE TRAINING.
ASPECT AND I'M HOPING THAT YOU
WOULD CONSIDER -- COMMISSION
MEMBERSHIP OF FROM THE FROM
ACADEMIA -- OR SOME TRAINING
THAT INCORPORATES SOME TRAINING
ASPECT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S I
THINK THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS SO THAT WE CAN
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE FEAR --
BUT WITH THAT I I DO WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR FOR THIS BILL I
THINK THIS IS.
THIS IS GREAT TO START DRESSING
THIS ISSUE THANK CENTER.
WHAT HAPPENED TAKE THAT IN
CONSIDERATION ABSOLUTELY?
OKAY IN ANY OTHER COMMENTS --
SIR STERN YOU DID IT -- YOU YOU
HAVEN'T SAID IT YET BUT I NEED
YOU -- TO I'M EXCEPT IMMENSELY
AMENDMENTS ABSOLUTELY AND I AND
I WILL IN THE PRESENTATION THE
NEXT I THINK IS IMPORTANT
COMMENT ABOUT HOW THIS
COMMISSION MIGHT RELATE TO
ANOTHER COMMISSION WE'RE GONNA
BE TALKING ABOUT BUT I'LL
RESERVE THAT FOR THE NEXT
DISCUSSION WITH THAT MAY HAVE A
MOTION.
MOTION SENATOR ARCHULETA WE CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AS BE SEVEN
THIRTY MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DOT.
HI DODD I WILK HI WILK AYE ALLEN
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA HI GORGEOUS.
GORGEOUS I BRADFORD.
CHANG CHANG AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO.
JONES JONES I NIELSEN I NIELSEN
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
VERY GOOD ELEVEN IS THERE ARE
LOTS OF IN THE BILL'S ON CALL --
THAT WOULD MOVED ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SB [inaudible]
SEVEN FIVE TWO VERY GOOD -- I'M
A VERY MILLENNIAL I'M GETTING A
CALL ON MY WATCH I FEEL LIKE
DICK TRACY APPEAR -- IN A THAT'S
A VERY NON MILLENNIAL REFERENCE
SO I THINK THAT'S A LITTLE
ANACHRONISTIC AYE YEAH -- THIS
BILL IS ABOUT.
ANOTHER CHALLENGING ISSUE IN THE
TECHNOLOGY SPACE WHICH GOES
BEYOND JUST THE FUTURE OF WORK
IN WHAT AUTOMATION COULD DO TO
OUR WORK FORCE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THE SPEED OF
INNOVATION WHEN IT COMES TO
CHANGES IN SOCIAL MEDIA -- AND
OUR BROADER TECHNOLOGY LANDSCAPE.
WE FEEL IS OUTPACING OUR ABILITY
TO TO TO NOT JUST TO REGULATE
BUT TO TRULY COMPREHEND IS
PUBLIC POLICY MAKERS AND HIS
GOVERNMENT -- THE THE IMPACT OF
BROADLY PROLIFERATED SOCIAL
MEDIA ON OUR DEMOCRACY.
ON OUR PUBLIC HEALTH -- ON THE
WAY WE GO ABOUT OUR DAILY LIVES
I DON'T THINK IS FULLY
UNDERSTOOD I KNOW WE WILL BE
WRESTLING WITH MANY ISSUES
AROUND PRIVACY -- AND HOW
CONSUMERS INTERACT WITH --
THEY'RE SORT OF THESE DATA
PLATFORMS THE GOVERNOR PUT OUT
IN HIS STATE OF THE STATE A
CONCEPT OF A DATED DIVIDENDS --
THIS BILL TRIES TO SORT OF SCOPE
OUT A BROADER APPROACH WHERE
CALIFORNIA MIGHT BE ABLE TO GET
A BETTER SENSE.
OF WHAT THE TRUE IMPACTS OF THE
SPEED AND SCALE OF INNOVATION
ARE THAT WE'VE SEEN.
AS A SOCIAL MATTER SO NOT JUST
IMPACTS ON WORKFORCE.
BUT TRULY THE IMPACT ON OUR
LIVES ON THE VALUE OF THE DATA
THAT WERE SENDING -- TO THE
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES THAT ARE
BEING UTILIZED TO TARGET ADS OR
TO GENERATE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN REVENUE -- WHAT'S HAPPENING.
TO YOUR KIDS AND GRANDKIDS AS
THEY USE INSTAGRAM FOR NINETEEN
HOURS A DAY AND LIVE THEIR LIVES
IN THIS PARADIGM THAT IS TRULY
IMPACTING OUR RELATIONSHIPS WITH
ONE ANOTHER -- AS WELL AS WITH
DEMOCRACY -- NOT JUST A YOUNG
PERSON ISSUE THOUGH FAKE NEWS
LAST CYCLE I THINK THE VAST
MAJORITY WAS SHARED BY THOSE
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER.
HI THIS IS NOT JUST MILLENNIALS
IGNORANTLY WANDERING THROUGH THE
WEB.
SO THE GUY IDEA HERE IS TO FORM
SOME KIND OF COMMISSION TO BRING
BOTH -- THE TOP ACADEMICS -- THE
TOP ECONOMISTS FOLKS FROM
PRIVATE SECTOR BUT ALSO CONSUMER
AND PRIVACY ADVOCATES TO TRY TO
DEVELOP SOME STRATEGY TO LOOK AT
WHAT AN EQUITY STAKE FROM THE
TECH COMMUNITY REALLY LOOKS LIKE.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR ME TO JUST
SAY.
YOU CAN OFFSET THE IMPACT YOU
MAY HAVE HAD ON JOURNALISM ON
DEMOCRACY THROUGH CHARITABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OR THROUGH SOME
OTHER -- STUDIES ARE REPORTS SIR
EVEN THE WONDERFUL EVENTS WE DO
OUR WE WE CODE IN THE DISTRICTS
ARE WE HELP EDUCATE YOUNG PEOPLE
ABOUT -- THE THE PITFALLS OF
SOCIAL MEDIA IT'S THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH -- WE ACTUALLY NEED TO
LOOK AT A SITTING DOWN THE TECH
COMMUNITY WHAT AN EQUITY STAKE
REALLY LOOKS LIKE IN THE FUTURE
ANYTHING THAT STARTS WITH
ACCOUNTING DATA AND HAVE AN
ACCURATE SET OF FACTS ABOUT.
WHAT THESE IMPACTS COULD TRULY
BE SO -- THIS IS SORT OF TAKING
THAT BALL AND RUNNING WITH IT
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S STATE OF THE
STATE AND TRY TO EXPAND UPON
THAT TO NOT JUST BE ABOUT A DATA
DIVIDEND CONVERSATION BUT
SOMETHING MUCH BROADER THAT WE
THINK COULD.
TRY PUBLIC POLICY IN YEARS TO
COME.
I'VE GOT HERE THIS BUSY UGLIES
HERE FROM COMMON SENSE MEDIA
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND HELPING US ALONG WITH THIS
MEASURE -- AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN CARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
ELIZABETH POLICIA I AM VICE
PRESIDENT POLICY FOR COMMON
SENSE.
WE ARE A NATIONAL NONPROFIT
ADVOCATING FOR HEALTHY DIGITAL
ECOSYSTEM.
WE REPRESENT MORE THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION PARENTS FAMILIES
STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS ACROSS
THE NATION WHO WANT TO LIVE IN A
WORLD WHERE THEY CAN HARNESS THE
POWER OF MEDIA AND TECHNOLOGY
FOR LEARNING AND LIFE.
THEY WANT THEIR PRIVACY
PROTECTED THEY WANT TO CONNECT
WITH FRIENDS WITH JOBS WITH THE
WORLD AND THEY WANT A VIBRANT
FUTURE.
THE SAME KIDS AND FAMILIES FEEL
THEY'RE PART OF A GRAND
EXPERIMENT THE INNOVATION
ECONOMY IS ONE IN WHICH WE ARE
TESTING DISRUPTING AND IN THE
END FAILING OUR NEXT GENERATIONS.
AND IT'S NOW TIME TO INNOVATE
FOR CHANGE.
AND I QUOTE.
IT IS NO LONGER MORALLY
ACCEPTABLE FOR TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES TO SAY WE JUST CREATE
THE PLATFORMS HOW PEOPLE USE
THEM IS UP TO THEM.
THAT IS MORALLY INDEFENSIBLE IT
IS GOOD COP OUT AND IS HURTING
CHILDREN AND ADULTS AND SOCIETY
AT LARGE.
THESE WORDS ARE FROM THE
NINETEENTH SURGEON GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES VACHE MARTY.
A FEW WEEKS AGO IN WASHINGTON DC.
THE NATION'S DOCTOR FOR FOUR
YEARS WHO CHALLENGE THE MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT TO TURN THE TIDE
ON THE OPIOID CRISIS.
CONTINUED IN THOSE COMMENTS.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS ASK
OURSELVES WHAT THE IMPACT OF OUR
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES ON?
OUR ON THE PEOPLE THAT WE ARE
SEEKING TO SERVE.
PART OF THAT INVOLVES
UNDERSTANDING AND INVESTING IN
THAT IMPACT AND THE COURAGE TO
ACTUALLY TAKE ACTION IF WE SEE
THERE MAY BE NEGATIVE IMPACTS.
EVEN IF THAT IMPACTS OUR PROFIT
WE HAVE TO FUNCTION WITH AN
ETHIC THAT PEOPLE AND THEIR WELL
BEING COME FIRST.
AND GOVERNMENT CAN PLAY A ROLE
BY CONVENING THE RIGHT PLAYERS
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION AND
PLACING THIS HIGH ON OUR
NATIONAL AGENDA.
CALIFORNIA WITH THE TECH EQUITY
ACT IS DOING JUST THAT.
ELEVATING HOW TECH IMPACTS
SOCIETY HI ON THE NATIONAL
AGENDA.
PRIVACY A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS IS ONLY THE
BEGINNING OF THE CONVERSATION
WHEN IT COMES TO RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITY.
AROUND TECHNOLOGY USE JUSTICE AN
IMPACT.
AND ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY WELL
CRITICAL IS ONLY THE THE
BEGINNING OF ADDRESSING EQUITY
FOR VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
THROUGH THE TECH EQUITY ACT WE
HOPE TO EXPLORE TAX IMPACT ON
ANY QUALITY.
OUR KIDS FUTURE THE FUTURE OF A
FREE PRESS AND TAX IMPACT ON OUR
DEMOCRACY AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
THIS WORK WILL HAPPEN BY
ENGAGING COMMUNITIES IN SECTORS
THAT ARE MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE AND
THAT HAVE AN WITH THOSE THAT
HAVE THE MOST AT STAKE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO REALIZE A JUST
AND EQUITABLE TECH FUTURE FOR
ALL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
TURN BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU WELL I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT STAFFED I AS AN
EDUCATOR FOR SO MANY YEARS I CAN
TELL YOU THAT DOWN.
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES AS
TEACHERS ON NOT GOING UP IN THE
TECHNOLOGY ERA THERE WERE NOT
UNDERSTANDING IN THE CLASSROOM
THE IMPACTS OF PARENT TEACHER.
ANYHOW I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR WITH THIS IS
IMPORTANT IN PARTICULAR AS IT
PERTAINS TO OUR STUDENTS AND
WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO DO SO
HOPEFULLY WE GET SOME DATA ON
HOW THAT AFFECTS.
OUR CHILDREN IN THE CLASSROOM
THANK YOU.
SO RUBIO CAN I COUNT THAT AS A
OCEAN [inaudible]
SIR WORKS.
WE'RE USING THE THE TERM
EQUITIES AND INEQUITIES.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES THAT?
DOES THAT MEAN.
I WE IS THIS A SYNONYM FOR
TAXATION.
RESEARCH.
I DO I DON'T THINK SO I I I
THINK THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
WAYS THAT TECHNOLOGY AND THE
INDUSTRY'S DRIVING IT -- CAN
TAKE AN EQUITY STAKE IN THE
CONVERSATION I THINK IT STARTS
WITH ACCOUNTING -- AND SORT OF
UNDERSTANDING.
THE IF IT'S POSSIBLE WE WE MAY
NOT GET TO A PERFECT ACCOUNTING
OF SOCIAL COST HERE -- IT'S NOT
THE SAME SAY IS A CARBON PRICING
EXERCISE WHERE YOU CAN.
GET DOWN TO THE EXACT DOLLAR PER
TON EQUIVALENT.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY COMMUNITY YET FULLY
UNDERSTANDS THAT THEY'RE NOT
SOMETHING SEPARATE FROM US BUT
THEY ARE US AND I GUESS THAT'S
THAT'S THE MEANING BEHIND THE
EQUITY POINT IS THAT -- HEY
THEY DON'T EXIST JUST IN THE
CLOUD THEY'RE NOT JUST A
PLATFORM -- THEY'RE HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY LIVE HERE.
HOUSING THE WORK FORCE -- THEY
OUGHT TO EXERCISE SOME EQUITY
STAKE IN WHAT THAT IS AND NOW
I'M I DON'T THINK THIS IS
SUPPOSED TO BE -- TAXATION
ORIENTED MEASURE PER SE -- I
THINK THAT IT'S A IT'S A BROADER
FRAMEWORK TO ALLOW OURSELVES
ACTUALLY INTEGRATE -- THOSE
COMMUNITIES IMPACTS INTO OUR
FUTURE PLANNING OF WE KNOW THAT
THE 85% OF FAKE NEWS ARE BEING
SHARED BY THOSE SIXTY FIVE AND
OLDER IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WELL MAYBE WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING.
EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS ON THOSE
COMMUNITIES AGAIN I THINK A LOT
OF FEAR DRIVES OUR CONVERSATION
AROUND TECH AND THAT SORT OF THE
RELATION BACK TO THE FUTURE WORK --
WE ARE SPECULATING RIGHT NOW AND
A LOT OF THE BLOW UPS THAT WE
SEEN OVER LAST COUPLE YEARS IN
TERMS OF THE USE OF FACEBOOK --
IT'S IMPACT ON JOURNALISM -- I
STILL BELIEVE IN A FREE AND OPEN
INTERNET AND I DON'T THINK THE
ANSWER TO THIS IS TO SHUT DOWN
FACEBOOK OR TO GO -- TAX GOOGLE
BECAUSE THE CURRENT PARADIGM IS
SIMPLY NOT WORKING.
IN I THINK YOU'RE HITTING ON
SOME REALLY IMPORTANT POINTS I
THINK.
THE TECH DYNAMIC IN ITS EVERYDAY
IMPACT OUR LIVES WERE CERTAINLY
HAVING TO CALIBRATE RECALIBRATE --
AND THERE SEEMS TO BE NO END IN
SIGHT BECAUSE IT'S ALWAYS A STEP
OR TWO AHEAD OF US.
I'M JUST WONDERING DO YOU HAVE
ANY CONCERN BY THE CREATION OF A
COMMISSION LIKE THIS.
THAT.
IT WOULD.
THE FIRST A CALCULATION ON
IMPACT.
AND THE MOTIVATION TO CREATE NEW
FUNDING STREAMS WILL BE SO
OVERWHELMING IN SEDUCTIVE.
THAT.
IT'S AN IRREVERSIBLE PROCESS --
WITH ITS OWN CONCLUSION.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE GONNA SEE
OUT OF THE FUTURE OF THIS AREA
OF REGULATION AND I AND I THINK
THE TECH MEANS ACTUALLY ASKING
FOR THAT REGULATION TO SOME
EXTENT THEY'RE SAYING PLEASE
HELP US THROUGH THIS BECAUSE WE
AS POLICY MAKERS ACTUALLY NEED.
TO GET OUR HANDS AROUND THIS.
IT MAY NOT BE WHAT YOU THINK IT
IS -- THE FUTURE OF A
NEGOTIATION BETWEEN ORGANIZE
PARTIES SAY -- CONSUMERS OF
SOCIAL MEDIA AND THEIR ABILITY
TO SAY THIS IS HOW MUCH VALUE
FOR INSTANCE FOR PROVIDING DO
YOU FACE BOOK -- NOT THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA EVEN BE
INTERESTED IN TAXING YOU BUT HOW
TO SAY EMPOWER -- YOU THOSE
THOSE SORT OF DATA CONTRIBUTORS
TO HAVE THEIR OWN NEGOTIATION
WITH A SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM NEW
CONSTRUCTS THAT.
I I I DON'T THINK WE HAVE IN OUR
LEXICON AT THIS POINT IN TERMS
OF TAXATION REGULATION BECAUSE
THIS.
THIS NEW PARADIGM IS SO
UNPRECEDENTED -- I DON'T THINK
IT'S JUST A STRAIGHT STALKING
HORSE FOR YOU KNOW A DIGITAL
SERVICES TAX OR SOME SOME
DIFFERENT KIND OF TEXT TAX THAT
LIKE THERE WITH WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THE U. K. THE U. I
THINK WE HAVE TO DO SOME
DIFFERENT HERE INCALIFORNIA SO.
I'M SORRY I DON'T HAVE SOME MORE
GRANULAR BUT I GOTTA GET PEOPLE
MUCH SMARTER THAN MYSELF --
TOGETHER WITH THE BEST PEOPLE --
THAT THE GOVERNOR CAN COME UP
WITH AND HOPEFULLY YOU WALKING
I'M OF COME UP WITH AND DO SOME
ANALYSIS HERE BECAUSE I DON'T
EVEN THINK WE HAVE THE
MECHANISMS IN MIND YET LET ALONE
THE ACCOUNTING.
IF THAT HELPS CAN'T STUDY WHAT
YOU CAN'T MEASURE THERE YOU GO --
THANK YOU YES -- CHIANG.
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION ANYONE
FROM THE TECH COMMUNITY THAT'S
SUPPOSED.
I DON'T I THINK THIS IS STILL
RELATIVELY NEW I THINK WE HAVE
VERY LIMITED SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AT THIS POINT -- I I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY.
ON EITHER SIDE PRIVACY OR TECH
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OTHER THAN
THE SYSTEMS OF OF COMMON SENSE
AT THIS POINT [inaudible]
YEAH.
A WE HAVE A MOTION ON THAT YET.
IF WE ALREADY YES SIR YES THAT'S
RIGHT CENTER RUBIO HAS A MOTION.
NOTHING ELSE WILL CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE FILE ITEM TWELVE SB SEVEN
FIFTY TWO MOTION IS TO PASS TO
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE DODD HI.
DODD I WILL.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE BARGES BARGES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD I CHANGE
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL HILL AYE WEST SO
[inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
THANK YOU THAT BILL ALLEGING.
HAVE AN ON CALL LET ME KNOW.
OKAY LET'S START WITH THE ROLE
FROM THE TOP PLEASE CONSENT.
CONSENT CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE WEST SO
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
OKAY.
FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE TWELVE
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I WAS SO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO WIENER [inaudible]
FILE ITEM. THREE SB THREE FIFTY
TWO MOTION IS YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE IS ELEVEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I WAS SO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible] TWELVE ZERO
FILE ITEM FOR SB.
SB FOUR TWENTY ONE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ON FOUR TWENTY ONE WE DIDN'T GET
A MOTION WE DID NOT GET A
MEASURE.
THAT POLICE [inaudible]
SENATOR HILL.
THE CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
MOTION IS.
DO YOU PASS YOUR PREPARATIONS
COMMITTEE.
DODD.
AYE DODD AYE WILK NO.
WILK NOW ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA AYE BARGES.
BARGES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL HI WES SO.
JONES.
NIELSEN ALL RIGHT NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER. NINE TWO TO
NINETY TWO THE BOOK BILLS ON
CALL ITEM NUMBER FIVE THIS BE.
FOR SIXTY FIVE BATES WE HAVE A
MOTION.
CENTER BORDERS MOVES CALL MENTAL
PLEASE PASS TO PREPARATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD.
AYE DODD AYE AYE WILK HI WILK
AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA AYE BARGES.
AGES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD I
CHIANG CHING AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL HILL AYE HUESO.
JONES.
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER. ELEVEN THIS
YEAR ON CLAY.
THAT'S GOT ELEVEN VOTES ON CALL --
THAT WE HAVE -- IT'S BE FIVE OH
ONE HER TADO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
CAN WE SKEWS ME ON FOURTH BY THE
CALL THE ROLL YOUNG.
ON ITEM NUMBER SIX SKEWS ME AS
BEFORE SIXTY NINE FILE ITEM SIX
SB FOUR SIX NINE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT BEAU IS TEN
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI I
WEST SO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
WIENER.
SO TWELVE ZERO IT'S ON CALL OKAY
YES -- BE FIVE OH ONE HER TAUGHT
A WE NEED A MOTION.
SO MOVED WE HAVE A MOTION BY
WILK MEASURE WILL MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
THIS IS SB FIVE A ONE DODD.
BY GOD I WILL HI WILK AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HIGH BARGES.
BARGES I BRADFORD BRADFORD I
CHANGE CHIANG AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO.
JONES.
JONES I NIELSEN HI NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO I WIENER [inaudible]
CAME. NINE TEN ELEVEN TWELVE
ZERO IT'S ALMOST TWELVE ZERO ON
CALL -- NOW WE HAVE SB -- FIVE
TWELVE CENTER PAN WE HAVE A
MOTION CENTER HILL.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD
AYE DODD AYE WILL.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARE TO LET AYE BARGES
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGE RIGHT CHIANG
I'D GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL AYE HUESO [inaudible]
JONES.
JONES NO NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER [inaudible]
HEY. ELEVEN TO ONE SEVEN A ONE
DOLLAR BILLS ON CALL -- WE MOVED
OUT -- TO ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
FIVE NINETY EIGHT MAY HAVE AMOTION ARE TO LET US SENATOR
ARCHULETA.
OR DOES NOT HAVE USED SENATE
MOTIONS TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS GORGEOUS.
BORDERS I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE.
WEST SO [inaudible]
JONES.
JONES I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER. FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN THE BILLS ON CALL.
FILE ITEM TEN SB SIX SIX NINE WE
NEED A MOTION.
TO MOVE.
MOTION IS TO PASS.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT.
THE BILL HAS A CHANCE TO CENTER.
READY TO VOTE FOR IT.
WORRIES FILE ITEM.
YOU'RE DOING A GREAT.
SHE'S ON HER WAY.
I CAN PRESENT IT IN HIS OWN
RIGHT.
IS THAT RIGHT THE FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AS BE SEVEN THIRTY MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE IS ELEVEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
RADFORD I WAS SO.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO AYE WIENER.
THIRTEEN ZERO ON THIRTEEN ZERO
THAT BILLS ON CALL.
LET'S SEE FILE ITEM TWELVE SB
SEVEN FIFTY TWO MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT COMMITTEE
CURRENT ROE ELEVEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN [inaudible]
WEST SO [inaudible]
JONES SAYS. SEVEN FIFTY TWO I
JONES I SO THAT'STWELVE ZERO
ZERO THAT BILLS ON A CALL.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AS BE SEVEN
SIX SEVEN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE IS.
SIXTY TWO ABSENT MEMBERS BOARD
YES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
RADFORD I CHIANG [inaudible]
WHY SO [inaudible]
JONES.
JONES NO PORTANTINO.
TINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER. NINETY THREE
IT'S í
BILLS -- OUT NINE THREE ONE CALL.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN ESSIE OUR
THIRTY ONE MOTION IS.
WE NEED A MOTION.
WE NEED A MOTION ON CENTER BRAD
ALL MOVED ALL MOVED THE BILL ALL.
MOTION IS TO BE ADOPTED AND
REFERRED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
BY.
DODD I WILL.
WILK AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I BRIDGES
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL AYE WESSEL.
JONES.
JONES I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY.
AS SENATOR BORDERS HI.
I DON'T KNOW NO CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF MINE.
I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH TO THIRTEEN
ZERO ZERO BILLS ON CALL ON CALL
[inaudible]
WHAT'S.
HE JUST RECESSES IN A PICKUP AT
RECESS WORK SO MY MY INTENTION
IS TO FINISH THIS MEETING YEAH
HERE SO WE CAN'T WE HAVE.
ONE SENATOR CON HERE'S ONE BILL
AND THEN WE'LL GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONE MORE TIME.
GONE FROM THE FIREPLACE IN A
FIRE -- WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE MEMBERS -- YES THIS IS JOY
SUPPORT BY SUPPORT.
CENTER THIS BILL -- ENJOYS THE
THE CHAIR SUPPORT.
I SAW MANY ASK YOU IN THE VICE
CHAIRS BOTH SIDES SO I'M GONNA
ASK YOU IN YOUR WITH THIS IS TO
BE BRIEF WE HAVE VERY LITTLE
TIME.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- PLEASED TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL SIX SIX NINE
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER FUND AND SAFE
DRINKING WATER TRUST -- AS YOU
KNOW THERE ARE OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEMS THAT.
ARE.
CHRONICALLY FAILING TO SERVE
SAFE DRINKING WATER AND A
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE IN SMALL
RURAL DISTRICTS.
ARE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES A
LOT OF IN MINE -- SO TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THIS
BILL WOULD SET UP A BOMB IT
WOULD ADDRESS THE ISSUES.
THAT WAS WE HAVE WE HAVE WATER
IN THE BOND.
WE HAVE MANY IN THE IN THE WATER
BOND TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SOME OF
THE IMPROVEMENTS SUMS TO SOME OF
THESE WATER SYSTEMS BUT WHAT WE
REALLY NEED.
IS A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE
TO ASSIST THE STRUGGLING PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS FOR THE OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS WHICH
GENERALLY CANNOT BE FINANCED
WITH EXISTING FEDERAL AND STATE
SAFE DRINKING WATER FIND SOURCES.
SO THE BILL WOULD ADDRESS THE
GAP IN FUNDING AT THE STATE BY
CREATING THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
TRUST WHICH WOULD BE CREATED AT
THE STATE TREASURY AND FINANCE
WITH GENERAL FUND DOLLARS DURING
A BUDGET SURPLUS YEAR.
LIKE THIS -- THE TRUSTS
PRINTABLE WOULD BE INVESTED AND
THE NET INCOME WOULD BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER FIND AT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. TO BE
ABLE TO FIX THE SYSTEM FIRST
WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CINDY TECH WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES.
TOGETHER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
WERE SPONSORED WE SUPPORT THE
BILL VIRGIN AYE VOTE I'LL BE
GLAD TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU.
CHAIR DIED MEMBERS DANIEL BLASTS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION AS IN THE
STATE OF WORKERS SPONSORING THE
BILL WE THINK IT'S A TERRIBLE
SOLUTION AND APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE.
NEXT WITNESS IN THE FULL FOR THE
FULL LINE YOUR NAME IN YOUR
POSITION.
BROWN'S OF AUSSIE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THURSDAY WORSE FOR THE MISSILE
WATER DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY
STRONG SUPPORT.
GREG'S LOT EXAM ON WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
CRAIG MORRISON REPRESENTING
ELSER VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THEIR DOLPHIN TO HAVE LEVY LEGAL
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
CAROLYN JANSEN WITH KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN THE
MOJAVE WATER AGENCY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DON GUILT ON GILBERT FOR ORANGE
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT SUPPORT.
GREG ANDERSON SACRAMENTO
SUBURBAN WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
I THE VERY BEST SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WATER AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
SECURE ROSS ON THE UP THE CITY
OF SANTA ROSA AND SUPPORT. TO
YOUR MESSAGE TODAY -- FOR
TIDEWATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
LORI JONES WITH THE MONTEREY
PENINSULA WATER MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF WHAT
SOME BILLS SUPPORT. TO LEARN AT
THE CANTON OF FOR YOU BUT WATER
AGENCIES FORT.
THE AUTOMATIC WITH THE CITY OF
ROSE FELONS PART.
TENNIS ELBOW ON IT WITH
CALIFORNIA GETS ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CLARITA VALLEY WATER
AGENCY MESA WATER AND SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY AND W. D. THANK
YOU IN SUPPORT. FOR THE THOMPSON
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
JOHNSON CLAIMED TO HAVE ALAMEDA
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
WELL ANYWAY THIS WORKING ON A
WHAT'S HER MEN ON BEHALF OF
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT IN
EAST VALLEY WATER DISTRICT BOTH
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THAT'S ALL ALSO MAY HAVE A
CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
CANDIDATES AGO WITH THE GOAL
GROUP ON BEHALF THE KERN COUNTY
WATER AGENCY SEN BERNIE OF
VALLEY MISS WATER DISTRICT LONG
BEACH -- WATER DEPARTMENT AND
SEVEN SEVEN WATER AGENCY IN
SUPPORT.
THE BUTLER BEHALF THE UNITED
CHAMBER ADVOCACY NETWORK A
COALITION OF LOCAL CHAMBERS HERE
IN THE SECOND A MARKET PLACE IN
SUPPORT.
FALCONS OFFICE HERE ABOVE THE
CITIES OF FAIRFIELD AND LAKE
WOULD AS WELL AS THE CENTER OF
OUR WATER ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ASHLEY WARNER ON BEHALF OF
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN OPPOSITION
WE APPRECIATE THE SENATORS
EFFORTS BUT WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THIS IS AN ELUSIVE
IMPARTIAL SOLUTION TO A VERY
REAL WATER CRISIS THANK YOU.
SIGN UP FOR ANA'S ON BEHALF OF
THE SACRAMENTO REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
HI JULIE NON ASK ABOUT ME HAVE
TO CONTRA COSTA WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
OBVIOUSLY THE WATER PEOPLE KNOW
HOW TO DO THIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT -- CENTER IS THERE
ANY -- OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
YES SIR.
HELLO THERE I'LL BE BRIEF
JENNIFER CLARY ON BEHALF OF
CLEAN WATER ACTION I REALLY
APOLOGIZE TO THE COMMITTEE AND
THE SENATOR CAFIERO THAT WE
DIDN'T GET OUR LETTER AND ON
TIME.
JUST WANT TO REINFORCE.
SOMETHING THOSE STATED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS AT THIS BILL FAILS TO
ADDRESS STATE SMALL SYSTEMS AND
DOMESTIC WELLS IS BETWEEN ONE
AND A HALF INTO IN CAL'S OF
CALIFORNIANS SERVED BY THOSE.
AND WE THINK THAT A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE BILL THAT HAS A
MORE CERTAIN FUNDING SOURCE IS A
BETTER IDEA THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT.
JONATHAN NELSON WITH COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER -- IN OPPOSITION WE
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT GETTING A
LETTER AND ONE ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
FELIZ THEIR AMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAVE CONSERVATION
VOTERS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED IN
WOODLAND OUR COMMENTS WITH
JENNIFER CLEARY'S.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
CERES AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU -- WE'RE GONNA TURN.
BACK AT CENTER CHIANG. TO THE
COMMITTEE YES -- MY FIRST LOOK
TO POSITION WAS TO THE BOARD OF
THE WALL IN VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT I WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR.
FOR A HER BILL AND I WOULD LOVE
TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU THAT
IN THE MOTION.
CLOSE MY CENTER CHIANG ANY OTHER
COMMENTS.
CALL THE ROLL CENTER WILK.
I SAW THE ANALYSIS EVERY SINGLE
WATER DISTRICT IN MY DISTRICT IS
ON THE BILL SO I LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AS WELL.
FILE ITEM TEN SB. SIX SIX SIX
NINE MOTION IS YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DOT.
HI DODD HI WILL.
AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HIGH BARGES
BARGES I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGE CHIANG AYE
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL.
HILL HILL HI WES SO.
WEST SO I'D JONES I'VE JONES I
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER.
SO FOURTEEN ZERO ON CALL FOR
THIS.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA.
TALENT SEARCH.
ON THAT BILL [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
FIVE OKAY -- THE TOP.
BULLETS KILL THE BILL NUMBER SO
WE CAN GIVE HER ACCOUNT.
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO THAT
BILL WILL BE ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BILLS OUT.
VERY MUCH OKAY WE'RE GONNA START
AT THE TOP -- AND THEY MORE --
SO MEMBERS CAN LEAVE WHEN
THEY'RE DONE.
SO LET'S GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONE
MORE TIME CONSENT CALENDAR.
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I WAS SO.
WEST SO I WIENER.
WHEN I WAS THE LOCATION
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO. FIFTEEN ZERO ON CALL
FOR THE LAST NUMBER FIFTEEN ZERO
THAT BILLS ON CALL.
FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS WEST SO
[inaudible] FIVE WEST SO I
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE WIENER.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ON FIFTEEN
ZERO ON CALL.
FILE ITEM THREE SB THREE FIFTY
TWO MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE TWELVE ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN.
ALLEN WEST SO.
WITH SO I AM PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE WIENER. FIFTEEN
ZERO ON CALL.
FILE ITEM FOR AS BEFORE TWENTY
ONE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BEAU IS.
NINETY TWO ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN [inaudible]
ALLEN HI [inaudible]
WHY SELL?
WHY SO I'D JONES?
JONES NO.
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE WIENER. TWELVE TO
THREE WELL TOLERATE THOSE ON
CALL.
FILE ITEM FIVE SB FOUR SIX FIVE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BEAU ELEVEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN.
ALLEN I WAS SO [inaudible]
JONES.
JONES I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE WIENER. TO
FOURTEEN ZERO ZERO ON CALL.
WHILE I AM SIX SB FOUR SIX NINE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BEAU IS TWELVE ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I WEST SO.
WHY SO I PORTANTINO?
PORTANTINO AYE WIENER. FIFTEEN
ZERO ZERO BALL BILLS.
FILE ITEM SEVEN SB FIVE A ONE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BEAU IS TWELVE ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I WAS SO.
WHY SO I PORTANTINO?
TINO AYE WIENER.
SO FIFTEEN ZERO ZERO OF ALL.
FILE ITEM EIGHT SB FIVE TWELVE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
APPS -- CURRENT -- ELEVEN TO ONE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES [inaudible]
WESTERN.
WHY SO I WIENER? TWELVE TO ONE
TWELVE THE ONE THAT BILLS ON
CALL.
FILE ITEM NINE SB FIVE NINE
EIGHT MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE FOURTEEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS WEST SO.
MY CELL AYE WIENER. FIFTEEN ON
CALL.
FILE ITEM TEN SB SIX SIX NINE
MOTION IS TO FASTER
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE FOURTEEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
K. FOURTEEN ZERO FOUR TWO ZERO
ON CALL.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB SEVEN THIRTY
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I WEST SO.
WHY SO I WIENER? FIFTEEN ZERO ON
CALL.
FILE ITEM TWELVE SB SEVEN FIFTY
TWO MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE IS TWELVE TO ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I WAS SO WHY SO I
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE WIENER. FIFTEEN
ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO BILLS ON CALL.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN SB SEVEN SIX
SEVEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BEAU IS.
NINE TWO THREE ABSENT MEMBERS
BOARD YES [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
WEST SO [inaudible]
WIENER. 1-356-789-2390 THREE THE
BILLS ON CALL FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN AS THE R. THIRTY ONE
MOTION IS TO BE ADOPTED AND THE
FIRST APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I WAS SO.
WEST SO I WIENER.
WIENER HI SIXTEEN ZERO SIXTEEN
ZERO THE BILLS OUT LET'S START
FROM THE TOP OF THE ROLE.
CONSENT CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS
WIENER.
RIGHT.
WIENER ICE SIXTEEN ZERO SIX ZERO
THE BILLS OUT ITEM ONE SB THREE
MOTIONS YOU PASS REPARATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIFTEEN
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS WIENER.
WIENER HI TWO THOUSAND ZERO
SIXTEEN ZERO FILE ITEM THREE SB
THREE FIFTY TWO MOTIONS YOU
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ABSENT MEMBERS WIENER.
WIENER AYE SIXTEEN ZERO SIXTEEN
ZERO BILLS OUT FILE ITEM FOR AS
BEFORE TWENTY ONE MOTION A YOU
PASS THROUGH PREPARATIONS
COMMITTEE ABSENT MEMBERS WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
IT'S TENDED TO TEND TO TO THE
BILLS OUT
FILE ITEM FIVE SP FOUR SIX FIVE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BOOK VOTE FOURTEEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS WEST SO [inaudible]
WIENER.
BILL I YOU KNOW.
FILE ITEM SIX SP FOUR SIX NINE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ABSENT
MEMBERS WIENER.
WIENER AYE SIXTEEN ZERO SIXTEEN
ZERO BILLS OUT FILE ITEM SEVEN
SB FIVE A ONE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ABSENT MEMBERS WIENER.
WIENER I SIXTEEN CHANNEL SIXTEEN
ZERO THE BILLS OUT HIGHLIGHT A
MATE SB FIVE TWELVE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TO ONE
ABSENT MEMBERS GORGEOUS
[inaudible]
WIENER.
BILLS OUT HERE I AM WANTING ONE
FILE ITEM NINE SB FIVE NINE
EIGHT MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ABSENT
MEMBER WINNER.
WE ARE AYE SIXTEEN ZERO SIXTEEN
ZERO BILLS OUT FILE ITEM TEN SB
SIX SIX NINE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FOURTEEN ZERO ZIPPO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
WIENER AYE FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN
ZERO BILLS OUT FILE ITEM ELEVEN
SB SEVEN THIRTY MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE FIFTEEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
WIENER.
WIENER AYE SIXTEEN ZERO SIXTEEN
ZERO BY ABOUT WHILE ITEM TWELVE
SB SEVEN FIFTY TWO MOTION IS TO
PASS TO LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE.
ABSENT MEMBERS WIENER.
WIENER AYE SIXTEEN ZERO SIXTEEN
ZERO BILLS OUT FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE.
NINETY THREE ABSENT MEMBERS
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
WEST SO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER I TELL TEN TO THREE AND
THREE THE BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AND WE GOT HIM
ON THAT.
SAID THAT CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS
BEFORE THE GEO COMMITTEE THIS
MAYBE IS